this is jocko podcast number 269 with
echo charles and me
jocko willing good evening echo good
evening and also joining us tonight is
dave burke
good evening dave good evening the
last podcast with leif we covered the
first part of this marine corps manual
which i don't even know if it's yet it's
not really a manual it's like
somebody made this it's called
the squad leader makes a difference and
i know who made it actually lieutenant
m abalde and lieutenant a.m
otero they made it at the war the marine
corps war fighting lab
in august of 1998 and
we're gonna push through the last few
pages of this book that we didn't cover
last time but then we're going to dive
deeper into the last example which i
actually moved to the end
and if you've ever wondered where these
podcasts come from
where my mind is going if you ever
wondered how i'm thinking through these
things this is an opportunity to follow
me down a path of discovery
to learn more about leadership to learn
more about human nature and about war
and about history and about fear and
about sorrow and about life and about
death
it's an interesting ride and it all
starts by picking up
where we left off with this this manual
the squad leader makes a difference the
subtitle is readings on combat at the
squad level
this book is a book that by its very
nature simultaneously
establishes and then reinforces a
culture
of maneuver warfare it
enforces that it establishes it
it it is decentralized command it's
literally a book
about the frontline leaders making a
difference and stepping up and leading
so here we go we're going to go back to
the book
right now
this one is sergeant
joe hooper u.s army
vietnam
1968.
sergeant joe hooper was a squad leader
with d company
2nd battalion 501st
infantry 101st airborne division
near way city a big salute right now
obviously to the
second of the 501st it's awesome
in january of 1968 way was captured by
the north vietnamese in the ted
offensive u.s forces fought desperately
to liberate
vietnam's ancient imperial city on
february 17th the company was assaulting
a defended position
along a riverbank outside way city when
it was attacked by rocket and machine
gun fire
the company had run into a defensive
position manned by two north vietnamese
companies in dugout bunkers
with the company pinned down by fire
sergeant hooper located the source of
the enemy fire he
rallied his squad and attacked across
the river
he overran several enemy bunkers this
bold maneuver inspired the rest of the
company to join the attack
during this attack some of sergeant
hooper's squad had been
wounded he ran out into the open to
retrieve them but was seriously wounded
himself
sergeant hooper refused medical
treatment and returned to his men
enemy fire continued to hamper the
attack sergeant hooper led his squad
through the bunkers
and buildings clearing a path for the
company and mortally wounding a north
vietnamese officer
when his squad came under direct fire
from a building
to their front sergeant hooper assaulted
the building himself
and killed the enemy with grenades and
rifle fire
upon reaching the final line of the
north vietnamese defenses sergeant
hooper destroyed
four bunkers by running the length of
the position
tossing grenades into each of the
dugouts
the enemy soldiers began to withdraw
from their positions
sergeant hooper then led his squad in
destroying the last two vietnamese
bunkers
with white phosphorus grenades
after the last pocket of resistance was
eliminated sergeant hooper organized his
unit into defensive positions
when the remainder of his company had
caught up sergeant hooper allowed
himself
to have his wounds treated sergeant
hooper played a major role in defeating
a large force
of north vietnamese d companies attack
forced the withdrawal
of north vietnamese reinforcements
attempting to enter the city
the at this action outside the city
weakened the nva defenders
inside way easing pressure on the
besieged city
and leading to the eventual liberation
of the imperial capital
and oddly enough it doesn't talk about
him receiving the the medal of honor or
anything after he's charging bunkers by
himself that's just
i guess that's just what we're doing
lessons sergeant hooper displayed
exceptional leadership his endurance
despite being wounded served
as an example to his squad and his
company
after taking initiative to assault
across the river sergeant hooper squad
assumed the role
of the company's main effort and
spearheaded the attack his exceptional
courage under fire
inspired the remainder of the company
sergeant hooper's combat decisions and
tactical leadership at the squad level
contribute contributed to his company's
success in this bitter fight
with the north vietnamese attempt to
reinforce the city halted
other forces were able to clear the city
this is um obviously this is the kind of
initiative
this is the kind of bias for action that
the marine corps talks about
all the time this is the kind of
initiative that we try and train leaders
to have
at every level that they are going to
make things happen
that's what we want and they've followed
up this quote
i've actually we actually hit this quote
before but i'm going to hit it again
we covered it a while ago on podcast 62.
ardent depict his book battle studies
listen to this though listen to this and
think about this
four brave men who do not know each
other
will not dare to attack a lion
four less brave men but knowing each
other well
sure of their reliability and
consequently of
mutual aid will attack
resolutely there is the science of the
organization of armies in a nutshell
when i was in south africa and i went
down to south africa and we worked with
some companies down there
and i heard that they wasn't in this
context
but they were talking about how back in
the day the the african tribes would
hunt
lions with spears but they would say you
know be like three or four guys
that would be able to take a lion
because they could maneuver in from
different angles
and they could eventually kill the lion
and this was after the conversation that
i don't know if you know this in south
in africa there's no
lions living out in the wild they're all
in these they're in these big giant game
reserves which are like the wild but
they're not
in the wild why is that because then you
have freaking lions roaming around
killing people i mean you're no match
for a lion
no match but if you've got some friends
three friends for i mean if you think
about the okay what are the odds if you
were to do this
the odds of a human beating a lion in a
fight
what are the odds what do you know like
it is not it's almost zero
how is it how is a human gonna kill a
lion in a fight right
okay okay you give him a spear
he has some kind of a chance but it
ain't good
when a freaking lion's coming at you
that thing's gonna
just it's a slaughter yeah
but as soon as you got some friends and
you can make some maneuvers
now you can not only can you win you
are confident enough that you do it on a
regular basis
that's decentralized command that's not
only decentralized command
that's what a good team is a good team
what does he call it
the the the if you're sure of the mutual
aid if i know you got my back
that's the strength of the team
i like how he he used the phrase and
that quote the science of organizations
and you think of science you think of
like all this research and all this
analysis and all the things right you
know what the science of organizations
i got relationships yeah i got you i got
your back that's the science that's all
you you need to know
uh i think that that quote that word
actually i wrote that down because that
that rung loudly of there's
actually it's not it's not complicated
this is not complicated you have to have
someone that you trust yeah if you trust
that person you'll do so much more with
someone
with just one other person that you
trust than what you do as a
on your own yeah and before i jumped on
and completed your sentence for you
you were gonna say relationships right
and i was already in the combat mode if
i got your back because that's you know
what do you
you don't you don't tell uh a lance
corporal hey you need to build a
relationship no you say you got to make
sure they got your back
right but if you're talking to a
business which is what we do
it's hey you got to make sure you're
building good relationships you got to
make sure that they know
they're going to give you that support
that mutual aid if you need it that's
what we're doing
and if we have that we're unstoppable if
we have that three of us can take a lion
corporal gregory
corporal gregory was a squad leader this
is vietnam 1971
u.s marine corps corporal gregory was a
squad leader assigned to the
first combined unit pacification platoon
3rd battalion 1st marines
the unit was the northernmost marine
unit in vietnam
corporal gregory's combat experience had
made him
an extremely proficient infantry leader
he placed strong emphasis on training in
the field
where wait back in the rear where they
had plenty of time to train no
in the field he played strong emphasis
on training in the field
he took every chance to conduct
opportunity
training with his marines
there were numerous duties required of
corporal gregory's squad
each day corporal gregory assembled the
squad and instructed them in a single
practical infantry skill
i'm gonna say that again every day well
they got all these duties
got all these news and the reason i'm
saying this is we hear this all the time
from companies
we didn't really have time to train so
so guess what no one has time to train
and if you think that this marine
corporal in the field has quote time to
train you're wrong so what does he do
every day he assembles the squad and
instructs them in a single
practical infantry skill
how long does that take ten minutes five
minutes seven minutes
while in a patrol base corporal gregory
instructed his men
in such skills as helicopter medevacs
close air support and call for fire
corporal gregory required that his squad
members continue their professional
development
every day after returning from patrols
corporal gregory's squad would work on
their marine corps
institute correspondence courses
pfc kirby a member of corporal gregory
squad
finished the marine corps nco mci in the
field in vietnam
in the field in vietnam corporal gregory
took the initiative to train his marines
and the skills required by his unit's
mission
and environment his training exceeded
the basic requirements
established by the marine corps and
created a squad that was
particularly well prepared for combat
the corporal used scenario-based
training
to run his men through multiple
repetitions of probable combat
situations
he made sure that each marine in his
squad understood their commander's
intent
their role in the mission and how each
man affected the
outcome of events during battle
corporal gregory is freaking squared
away
and by the way everything that i'm
saying right now apply it to what you're
doing
in your company in your business
think of think of how much you could do
to help how much you could do to train
your people
not because you've got two weeks
allocated to train your personnel but
because you got 20
minutes to review with them how this
product
works or how this piece of equipment
functions or what to do in an emergency
situation
or how to handle a client
it was not long before corporal
gregory's training
proved vital on the night of february
14 1971 corporal gregory
and his unit came under every heavy
attack
corporal gregory was killed
yet because the squad was so well
trained and understood what it had what
had to be done
the squad was able to meet the challenge
and skillfully
engage the enemy corporal gregory's
exemplary leadership in the weeks prior
to the attack had prepared his marines
for this
firefight the enemy was repulsed and the
squad held
its position in the morning over
30 dead nva were found in the area
surrounding the squad's position every
marine in the squad realized
that it was corporal gregory's training
emphasis
that had won the battle and saved their
lives
lessons corporal gregory displayed
outstanding initiative in training his
marines
he assumed the responsibility for
preparing his marines for the demands of
combat
this training greatly exceeded the
established standards of the marine
corps
which by the way are no no low standards
and directly contributed to the combat
success and survival of the unit after
corporal gregory's death
corporal gregory you and by the way if
they ended up with 30 dead
nva over 30 dead nva that was a big
force that attacked
his unit
corporal gregory used whatever time was
available to instruct his marines and
hone their professional skills
this aggressive opportunity opportunity
training was necessary because few units
could conduct
formal training in the combat zone i
talked about this on ef online the other
day
i absolutely learned more from informal
training than i did from formal training
during my time
in the navy without question it's not
even close
if you were to remove all the informal
lessons i learned i would be an idiot
do you find that the formal training is
like
kind of sorts itself out to be more
valuable early on
explain so like you know how you have
like basic training
right that's where you learn like all
the the formal protocols where everyone
has to essentially do the same thing
under very similar circumstances and
then the informal training
seems to and i'm totally just thinking
about jiu jitsu right now
and at work i guess where when you get
informal training that's when you're
trained up on all the basics
it's kind of like college in a way you
know you have like all these
prerequisites like hey you guys all got
to know this
this this this and know it good and then
later on then maybe we'll send you out
to a specific company or whatever
to learn kind of what they do and then
you can start to apply these things in
specific situations
i think the example to use would be
let's say you went to some kind of a
technical school
like being a doctor being a mechanic
being a air conditioning repairman
you're going to learn some technical
stuff in the classroom yeah but when do
you really get good
it's doing the job it's when some it's
when someone pulls you aside and says oh
yeah when you see this here's the
problem
right when you when you when you go here
here's what you need to do when you see
this symptom
from a patient here's what's actually
happening it's all that
informal training that and maybe i'm
wrong about doctors because i don't know
what
medical school is like but i can only
imagine
that you get a heck of a lot better
by once you're in the field and you're
doing surgeries
and someone says hey here's a better way
here's the technique you need to use
you know something like that yeah yeah
it's like you know huh you i think it
was a it was a book you were reading a
long time ago where where they'd have a
name
shoot it might have been might have been
one of our guests i don't know but
they'd have a name for the people who
don't
do i think it was in the army where they
don't do it they just do all the theory
and they call them something like nerds
or something uh
i don't know anyway but yeah there's the
people who know and they essentially
they know
what to do and what the protocols are in
a vacuum
yeah but once you start when you get out
out there in the field in the real world
kind of thing that's where that informal
like no
this isn't by the book over here you got
to watch out for this because
and there's also a difference between
just learning from experience
which is hey i did this operation here's
some mistakes that i made and all
and that's just experience classroom is
classroom i'm talking about
in between where you're you know
someone's pulling you inside and say hey
jonco when you start to see this develop
that's not a good call here's a call
that would be better to make and here's
why
it's not formal training it's my platoon
chief telling me something
yeah it's my lpo my leading petty
officer saying
hey hey new guy here's what you need to
do when you see that unfolding and you
go okay roger that it's not formal
training
but that's where you learn and it's not
just experience either
experience alone would take you way
longer yeah yes
than informal training like how many
okay jiu jitsu example
here you learn the arm lock now we're
rolling
yeah and you try and arm lock me and i
say hey
echo if you if you don't squeeze your
knees together it's real easy to get out
here
put look give me your arm boom oh yeah
you feel that try and pull your arm up
oh i can't oh okay yeah that's because
it's all
because i'm squeezing my knees okay look
the instructor guarantee the instructor
said squeeze your knees
yeah but you need that informal
assessment of your actual situation to
realize
oh i i see what i need to do yeah
exactly right that's exactly what i was
thinking too
did you jets uh was the
i mean you have to get informal training
once you're in the
once you're done with the rag yeah i
think
just how you described it the the
you talk about like being on site or
being in the field or doing it like that
you talked about even just the air
conditioner repair man what that looks
like
the way you described what life would be
like if all we ever did was formal
training
you'd have no context for anything you
wouldn't even know how it applies
so i think that's true in in
certainly in my case in in aviation i
don't think it's any different like
everything is taught by the book
everything is formal training in the
beginning
it's all these things and the minute you
get the airplane to get up in the sky
and you are feeling things in a
different way it's really hard to apply
them
because you learned it on the ground and
the context of
the informal hey hey listen look do you
see that yeah yeah
that's what it means in the book when it
says this that's what it looks like and
go oh man i would never
be able to understand that from reading
it in a book they have to train
you have to get a translation yeah you
do translations you have to be able to
see
and feel it and that will not happen
in formal training it's important to
realize
if you have some experience and you have
people that
are on your team the amount of knowledge
that you can transfer to them
is so valuable and and the reason i'm
pointing this out is because a lot of
times you forget that
right you think you've been doing this
for a long time you don't think it's a
big deal hey this is just what you do
you don't you you forget you forget that
you've learned all this
but taking that and saying hey hey hey
hey pal come over here let me show you
something let me show you how this works
let me show you a better way to do that
let me show you
a little trick it's very powerful not to
mention when you invest in people
like that for 10 minutes for 10 minutes
you're helping them and you're building
that relationship
which is what this whole thing is that
we're talking about yeah and i wrote
down while you're talking
that telling that story of that corporal
is
i just wrote down i always take notes
that's all i do in this podcast i just
take notes i
take these things home and i write them
down and i keep them and i find places
where they apply and as you
know they apply everywhere and this this
idea of this guy training his people is
actually the best thing he can do to
take care of them it's the best thing he
can do
it's the best thing any leader can do to
help them not give you a break or not
give you free time and
yeah of course there's a balance there
but the best thing he could do
is prepare them to be in a position and
i think the reason that stuck with me is
that
when we talk about decentralized command
which we talk about all the time
in business the scenario that always
plays out is
the reason why decentral one of the
reasons why decentralized command is so
important is that your people have to
know what to do when you're not around
that's pretty obvious but the scenarios
are usually you're on vacation
you're on a different shift you've got
the day off not that you're dead
so when you kind of think of it in these
contexts of what he was doing is being
able to prepare them to be successful
without him being around is in the worst
possible situation if of literally him
dying in that situation
is the best thing he can do so so the
same thing doesn't happen to them
is train them even if it's five
minutes at a time is that's how he kept
those guys alive and
that is something that you can you can
translate to almost any situation
yep your family you know we talk about
this in the code the protocol
the evaluation it's like hey what can
you do your family
can you give your family five minutes of
training to pass on knowledge that you
have
more lessons here corporal gregory
realized that combat is a dynamic
environment which takes a heavy toll on
leaders within
an infantry company he trained his
subordinates to be able to assume his
role
this saved the lives of his men during
the chaos of battle
after his death the men of corporal
gregory's squad performed well performed
well because
they had confidence in their training
and in themselves a confidence that was
instilled
by corporal gregory's leadership you
know when we were talking when we talk
about confidence
how do you get confidence your
confidence do work you get confidence by
doing something get confidence by
doing something not doing it well doing
it again doing a little bit better doing
it again doing it even better
that's where confidence comes from
that's where it should come from
otherwise it's false confidence
maybe i should just stop talking because
the way he that was written in the book
was a lot better than the way i said it
but
well here's what's really cool so they
have a if
we he mentions he mentions uh uh kirby
in this
pfc kirby a member of the
of corporal gregory squad that finished
this uh nco mci
in the field well i have a quote from
him not from vietnam but from 1998
and now sergeant major r.b kirby
said the very worst night of my tour in
vietnam
when we were involved in a major
firefight and we were losing marines
our squad survived as a result of the
corporal's
training we are alive today because of
him
next one corporal abals
british army falklands
1982. in 1982 argentina invaded the
falklands
falkland islands in the south pacific
south atlantic ocean
the islands had been british territory
since british days as an imperial power
not willing to give up its territory
britain sent a task force to the islands
in order to reclaim them
after an amphibious assault british
forces pushed their way across the
islands
the second battalion of the parachute
regiment known as tupera
of the british army was ordered to
attack the argentinian forces
of goose green it was to be the first
pitched battle between british and
argentinian forces
the land bridge between goose green and
the town of darwin was the only way for
forces to move between
east falkland island and lafonia island
if tupera could not break through to
goose green the british would have to
spend valuable time
mounting another amphibious assault of
the falkland islands
corporal abals was a section leader
equivalent to a squad leader in
a company tupera a company's mission was
to attack along the battalion's eastern
flank and assault the town of darwin
on the night of 27 may 1982
tupera attacked goose green the
argentinians were well prepared for the
attack and the paratroopers could
advance only
yards at a time as the sun rose
the battalion was left in a precarious
position tupera was stalled
pinned down in the open by argentinian
mortar and machine gun fire
a company was trapped in a crossfire
between the argentinians on goose green
and those in darwin this is a nightmare
scenario
you're in a crossfire receiving both
mortar and machine gun fire
realizing that the trap could only be
broken by persistent aggressive action
corporal of balls decided to continue to
lead his squad in assaulting
enemy positions seeking to break the
deadlock
himself the commanding officer of tupera
charged a machine gun nest and was shot
dead
the commander of a company kept the
event quiet not wanting to demoralize
the troops
whose predicament seemed to worsen at
this critical point in the attack
at that moment corporal balls led an
assault
upon an argentinian position he decided
to fire a 66 millimeter shoulder
launched anti-tank rocket into the
bunker
the penetration of this rocket caused
such a magnificent explosion
which was followed by silence the first
flags have surrendered then began to
surface from the argentinian positions
the argentinians had been demoralized by
the utter destruction of this single
bunker
and the ruthlessness of corporal abal's
resolve
this allowed a company to turn its full
attention toward
goose green momentum gathered behind the
british attack
in the next 24 hours two para opened
the route to lafonia island
corporate ball's persistent
aggressiveness had broken the will of
the defenders this action proved to be
pivotable
pivotal in a company's attack two para
two pairs victory at goose green
assured a british victory for the
falkland campaign
lessons corporal abal's squad level
action effectively turned the tide of
the battle at goose green
this is this is an example of how an
aggressive tactical action can have
effects
out of all proportion to the size of the
action
his command decisions fully supported
both his company and battalion
commander's intent his spectacular
assault of that particular
bunker affected the morale of both sides
crushed the spirit of the argentinians
and passed the initiative and momentum
to british forces
and proved to be the action needed to
continue the british advance
after this action argentinian soldiers
began to surrender rather than die in
combat
one person a corporal
makes one move and it changes the the
the the tide of this battle by the way
moments after his commanding officer was
killed
heroically assaulting a machine gun nest
corporal ball's courage leadership and
determination propelled him to persevere
and achieve decisive results in
extricating his unit from a desperate
situation
when all else fails perseverance
prevails and if you want more on the
falkland islands podcast 88
excursion to hell
sergeant david c freeman u.s army
vietnam 1966
during operation crazy horse
and pay attention to that name operation
crazy horse we're going to go deep
in the vin fan valley in june of 1966 a
company of
montanyard troops led by special forces
advisors landed at
lz monkey for a search and destroy
mission sergeant freeman
a member of the command element was the
fourth senior man in the unit
soon after landing the company attacked
and secured a bunker complex
the company suffered some casualties and
a helicopter medevac was requested
the company moved back to lz monkey with
their wounded
at the lz the company began receiving
heavy small arms fire
the command element around sergeant
friedman was devastated
the situation demanded rapid action
sergeant freeman grabbed a radio and
took command of the company
he called in helicopter gunships
coordinated supporting arms
and reorganized his defenses the
helicopter pilots flying above the
battle were amazed at his coolness under
fire
under sergeant freeman's competent
command the perimeter held all night
and the enemy eventually withdrew
stepping up
lessons sergeant freeman a well-trained
nco was prepared to lead his company in
combat
he knew the techniques and procedures
for air support supporting arms
medevac and company defensive positions
and they kind of rattle that off
and and one thing that the marine corps
does really good in this manual is they
hit on the fact that you got to have the
skills
you got to have these fundamental skills
of combat leadership
that the technical and tactical skills
of combat leadership meaning
how to call for air support how to call
for supporting arms how to call for
artillery
how to call for medevac these are
technical skills that you have to have
and they reinforce that throughout this
book so if you're in a leadership
position you think well you know i'm not
gonna have to do that no actually you
better you better you better go
and dig in and figure out how to do
these things
in addition to his technical knowledge
he was able to match these abilities
with strong leadership and cool
competence in the face of disaster
because of his experience and
situational awareness sergeant freeman
knew that rapid action was required once
again
what do we see we see someone that's
taking action
he immediately took control of the
situation making decisions and issuing
orders
and extricated his company from a
perilous situation
and here's a little klaus wits
on war which we haven't covered yet
it's sort of one of those ones
is it like uh not playing the obvious
one
you know we haven't done that one yet
the end for which a soldier is recruited
armed and trained
the whole object of his sleeping eating
drinking and marching
is simply that he should fight at the
right place
and at the right time
check all right now here we go
here we go so this
section that i'm about to read actually
came earlier in
the manual and i pulled it out and i put
it at the end this is the last one of
these examples
and and there's a reason why and it
immediately struck me when i saw it
so the title of this section is just
sergeant first class u.s army vietnam
1966. so soon as i read that i was kind
of surprised because
all the other ones they give the
person's name something and why why
why aren't they saying this guy's name
this is a top secret mission well
no this is 1998 there was no no more
secret missions
so why aren't we explaining this it
becomes obvious
when i read it why they just called this
individual sergeant first class so here
we go
in may of 1966 sea company of 1st
battalion 12th cavalry
first cavalry division established a
mortar firebase
at lz hereford in the wing fan valley
so this is actually part of and i'll get
into this
this is part of that earlier operation
that we mentioned
the position was 150 meters long and 40
meters wide the upper slope was covered
in six
foot high elephant grass the mortar
section was led
by a sergeant first class no name given
his position lay on a hill which had
previously been occupied by viet cong
gorillas he formed his men
in a weak perimeter
we're not off to a good start arranged
in a u-shape
with the curve facing uphill and set up
the mortars in order to provide
support for the company the main body of
the company went off to patrol the
valley below
leaving the 22-man mortar section to
defend their own position
the men fired off a few rounds to seat
their base plates the sergeant decided
to give the men a break
and did not order anyone to dig in or
examine the area around the perimeter
no security patrols were sent out the
men
lounged ate sea rations
and walked around in the open in the
jungle heat it seemed like a day at the
beach
at 13 30 an enemy machine gun opened up
at a range of 50 meters
from the elephant grass uphill of the
mortar position
a 200-man unit of vc had been waiting to
ambush
the lax mortar unit machine gun fire was
followed by rifle fire and grenade
attacks
the rest of the company which had gone
down the hill on patrol the rest of the
company took 35 minutes to rush back to
the devastated mortar position
the enemy had withdrawn and left only a
handful of dazed
survivors
the failure of the sergeant to properly
lead his unit
enforce basic security measures or
prepare for enemy contact
led directly to disaster
with its support element eliminated the
company was not able to establish its
patrol mission
which in turn negatively affected the
battalion's mission
in the vin than valley
so i read that and of course i
think about okay what does this mean and
they
hadn't given away any names right so
they didn't give this guy's name but
they had given away
a date may of 1966 they'd given away
the lz lz hereford
so i start to do some research and it
turns out that
this battle this specific battle was
written about in a book
on vietnam called battles in the monsoon
and this is an how to print book
but i was really curious what happened
wait what happened
so i found this out of print book
ordered it and
the book battles in the monsoon
is a book full of
basically a bunch of short little
stories and this particular story
this particular section in this book
about this battle
is called men facing death
so let's hear a little bit more detail
about this
situation
by the way this is all operation crazy
horse by the night of 21 may the battle
of
vinthan valley appeared to be slowing to
a stop with the enemy fractionalized and
everyone running for cover
l landing zone hereford that well worked
over slope where the initial explosion
has occurred had occurred and
i'm skipping to this specific they give
a little bit of background
this lz hereford had been used a bunch
it looked like one of the safest places
in the fire zone
such had been the constant the
consistency of armed traffic in and out
of it
so this was a lz that was getting used
all the time
that was about how colonel john j
hennessey thought of it when he decided
on a special mission for charlie company
first of the 12th for the following
morning it was a courteous gesture
the main object being to return charlie
company to its parent battalion
but before doing so hennessy planned to
ask a small favor in return
the company under captain don f warren
a taciturn georgian who had been with
his
same unit since winning his gold bars in
1961.
this guy's been in the same unit since
for five straight years
he was on the perimeter in hill on hill
766 several ridges beyond hereford
the airline distance was about 3000
meters hennessey
directed warren to sweep back over the
high ground to hereford after sunup
unworried about that passage he was most
concerned that charlie company should
reconnoiter the lower slopes beyond the
landing zone
which thus far no one had prowled
that task done it could rejoin the
battalion in the valley not far away
hennessey had no reason to be suspicious
he was merely being cautious
the ground around hereford had not been
worked over carefully for several days
captain jack cummings and alpha company
were in perimeter on the landing zone
at this same hour they were not left
holy
they were left they were not left wholly
undisturbed but the occasional sniper
rounds and grenades
that innocuously bitten to their ground
were attributed to enemy stragglers
so there's a company there they're
getting hit occasionally but there's
just a bunch of stragglers is what
they're assuming alpha company needed to
be back
so they send in charlie company word of
that
was a foot and that reached major
charles
seiler at the on at on k shortly after
hennessy gave his order the division's
public information officer was
entertaining a visitor
and a weighing problem all his own
belatedly
drawn by the news that operation crazy
horse was racking up a score
war correspondent sam caston
a 32 year old senior editor of look
magazine had just arrived in camp
pursuing a theme worthy of hemingway
casting was the only correspondent drawn
to the battle
he said to seiler i wish to know the
thoughts of men
facing death so that's what this war
correspondent says sam caston
seiler voiced an honest doubt that the
quest was logical men's fears and
reflections not being all of one kind
this
and the soldier hardly knowing how he
thinks about death until he feels
he is dying
it is just not the subject that makes
for easy talk among
combat men so that's kind of weird right
we got this
this reporter saying hey i want to go
get some men facing death
at the time general norton had put the
on k
position on semi-alert and the whole
camp was a stir sciler and his staff
were in the bunkers
around the press camp realigning some of
the sandbags you don't have to worry
about this ground tonight
said castin i'm the luckiest reporter
alive wherever i go nothing happens
so even this guy who's looking for
problems he's got that
attitude where i'm gonna go look for
problems i'm not gonna find them
seiler remembered the words thinking
them slightly ironic in view of what
casting was looking for this guy wants
to go find people facing death but then
he says hey don't worry about
there going to be any problems because
i'm so lucky that nothing's going to
happen
there's a big hill not far from here
where a lot of men have died in the last
few days he said
then i want to get up there first thing
in the morning said castin and by the
way i intend to follow the subject all
the way through
see the coffins in which you place the
bodies
we put them in rubber bags said seiler
grumley
hoping to close the conversation but
casting continued to fret about getting
up to hereford
soon after dawn syler broke off work to
arrange for castin's certain departure
these were the circumstances which
resulted in caston being delivered to
hereford by the same helicopter that
carried
ammunition coffee and a hot breakfast to
cummings and alpha company
his first hours were unrewarding that
the unit was too busy stacking supply
equipment for an early getaway
to talk with casting about death besides
the morning was disarmingly fair and
quiet
warren and charlie company charlie
company meanwhile were beating their way
along the ridge
on the way back from hill 766 having
broken camp at 100 a fairly wide trail
runs for the top of the scarp
for the entire distance so
fast forward a little bit alpha company
was lifted from lz hereford when charlie
company arrived at high noon
casting stayed on the landing zone
warren talked
briefly to lieutenant colonel ruff
rutland p beard jr the battalion
commander and his
s3 major role
it was arranged
that warren and the main body of the
company would continue their stroll
downslope through the trees and across
the river
now i just want to call out these words
it was arranged
because we're going to get some more
information so you've got the you've got
the
battalion commander talking to the
company commander
and they come to this is what it says it
was arranged
that warren and the main body of the
company would continue through the
stroll through the downslope through the
trees and across the river
the mortar platoon would remain on
hereford to cover
its further advance with the with fire
from the 81 millimeter tube so now you
can see where we're going the
sergeant first class of the mortal
platoon that we talked about
from the squad leader makes a disc
difference this is the guy
this is the guy
the platoon 22 strong was led by
sergeant robert l kirby
a 29 year old negro from los angeles
slight of frame solemn faced kirby is
rated
one of the stoutest hearted fighters
in his brigade so that's a little
different right
now we're now we're calling this guy one
of the stouted stoutest hearted fighters
in the brigade
but in this in the in the reflections
from
the manual he's you know not going to do
a good job
and by the way he's going to get left
with 22 people and a mortar platoon
which is again we'll dive more into that
fewer numbers his men
seeming seemed sufficiently armed each
carried 300 more rounds for their m16s
and from two or four from two to four
hand grenades
the one heavy weapon was the 81
millimeter mortar
for which kirby had only 18 rounds
that with the tube was as much weight as
the men could carry
so sufficiently armed is an interesting
way of saying it
because we know that an m16 with 300
rounds an m16 is fine
a mortar is fine but if you get into a
legitimate gunfight
there's something that you need called a
machine gun and you need a few of them
and they don't have any
not good
moreover it had been agreed that as
promptly as the descending company
passed beyond the range of the platoon
that the platoon would be lifted out by
chopper alpha company had a hundred or
so
mortar rounds behind kirby reckoned he
would not need them
caston the the reporter had decided to
stay on hereford instead of moving with
the company column
it's an interesting decision it's an
interesting decision because if you
would think if you're looking for
to get in the fight you would
oh they're going to go with it i'm
sitting on this kind of lz
we're kind of it's almost like a little
bit secure and these guys are going to
go on patrol i would probably think
i'd go on patrol casting for whatever
reason
he says he decides to stay up there on
hereford
and it's kirby the sergeant who says
it will happen here if anywhere
uh no sorry that's casting that says to
kirby it will happen here
if anywhere like that we're gonna get in
combat and kirby says about that you're
dead wrong
and he honestly felt that way though as
he looked about what he saw of his
position hardly warranted such assurance
it was all wrong from any reason to
tactical view
so now this is kirby he he's looking at
the situation even though he says yeah
it's not going to happen here
he knows it's all wrong from a tactical
perspective
the landing zone at hereford was by then
a burned off trampled and
rumpled rebel strewn about the size of a
professional basketball court running
lengthwise down the edge of a ridge
it scorched earth and grasses were less
apparent than the foxholes distributed
more or less evenly around the oval
shaped perimeter originally these had
been
enemy spider holes and were subsequently
enlarged by
american occupancy the trouble was that
kirby did not have enough men
to round out his holding so the position
became a
u pointed a u pointed up up slope
and again this is where's there's that
you can see the similarity here from
from the manual the uphill open end
fronting toward the high ground was not
covered by weapons present
since the platoon was sighting its
pieces downslope
the company having gone that way and
weapons platoon so
they have a u-shape and they're like
well the platoon went that way so we
don't really need to have much there
and that's where he decided to put light
and not any any protection in that
direction
in neither direction was the prospect of
a fight was a prospect good if a fight
was to be forthcoming
there was beauty everywhere but there
was beauty everywhere for to sue the eye
upslope and bordering the very edge of
the defended ground was a sea of
elephant grass standing six
to eight feet tall downhill there was a
sheer and rocky precipice extending 30
feet and giving away to an extension in
the field of tall grasses
which also invested the flanks greenness
was all about except where the men
looked to their weapons
the company took off down so now here
goes the company the company took off
down the steep
clutching to the rocks creepers and
creepers for balance no prep
no preparatory artillery fires or air
strikes had been put on the slopes
around hereford because of warren's
movement
the earlier presence of alpha company
and the all-round feeling that crazy
horse operation was slowing to a halt
this operation been going on for
a pretty long period of time there's
been all kinds of activity
they didn't feel like they needed to do
any preparatory fire for this patrol
kirby worried less about his platoon
than about the movements
and enterprise of castin the reporter
the men had gone to ground the
correspondent was moving from position
to position standing erect
taking photographs and asking numerous
questions wanting to protect castin
he did not know how to object his
freewheeling
though he realized that his movements
were describing the limitations of the
force
in fact these things little
mattered casting was enjoying himself
hugely
he asked kirby how do you how do you
feel about these things
kirby answered if you think you're going
to get a story out of this platoon
you're wrong nothing will happen here
casting continued with his rounds of the
perimeter snapping pictures and asking
the men how do you feel
kirby lost interest and cast and kept
moving the position
of the mortar of one mortar was near the
bottom of the sloped lz
just inside the u where the crew had dug
a little pit
at approximately 1300 the platoon began
supporting the descending company
with the fire of the 81 millimeter
mortar the range 800 meters
it takes a while to hack through the
jungle captain warren got kirby on the
radio
and told him bring it closer which kirby
tried to do so now you got the platoons
up there
they're dropping mortars in front of the
platoon that's
that's driving through the jungle
an hour later warren called kirby again
this time the message was an uplift said
warren choppers are incoming to take you
out within 30 minutes
so they're just about done so just to
recap
you've got the platoon you've got the
mortar platoon in this
landing zone you've got a the rest of
the company pushed
down the hill and they're just on a
patrol and eventually they're so far
away
that there's no point in the mortar
platoon being up there anymore so now
helicopters are going to come grab them
and take them out
30 minutes that was what warren and
kirby both thought but the choppers had
put down at landing zone
savoy hennessey's command post in the
valley
just to make certain orders that the
orders given
still stood from their delay wholly
unfaltable
came rocking general jack norton rocking
the high command rocking us all kirby
got off
his 17th mortar round in support of the
advancing company
that being the last one he fired
remember they had 18 rounds he just
fired a 17th round
then the thing happened there was no
advance warning
sergeant louis buckley and pfc wade
taste were still collecting the company
water cans and other materiel for the
flight
moving carelessly in the open even as
was
correspondent castin the other men
including kirby stayed put in their
foxholes
that they did so was less a sign of
their alertness than of their
forthcoming
operational routine once lodged in
position they had not moved to
scout its surroundings the long trek via
the jungle trail had half
had them half bushed so they're tired
over much of the distance they had to
move they were crouching because the
tiny overhang there was no shade where
they were sprawled the sun beat directly
down on them and it was not less than
100 degrees
the word was passed from hold a hole
that they were returning to home base
nothing much else
not even the eccentric movements and
questions of cast and
interested them the hour must have been
about 13
30. from upslope and from not more than
50 yards away
came a f came the fire of a heavy
machine gun
its bullet stream was dead on the mortar
the first rounds ripping through the
tube as if the weapon
had already been zeroed in thereafter it
beat directly on the mortar put
pit with never a pause
so came kirby's first warning that he
was engaged he yelled out
fire but it was superfluous
though he did not know it being too
close to the mortar
a split second before kirby had reacted
his own men had started the fight
on the left of the inverted u it would
have been the right flank
had these men been facing uphill whence
the fire was specs
four paul jay harrison and charles
stuckey
had seen three enemy skirmishers moving
in through the elephant grass
not five meters beyond their foxholes
their m16s their m16 fire signal
detection of movement
to which the enemy machine gun instantly
responded
as swiftly as those three weapons spoke
from the elephant grass on three sides
of the perimeter rifle
fire cracked and kirby sensed that his
position was almost totally enveloped so
he gets the feeling that we're
surrounded
he yelled to his radio man spec for
john f spranza call company get them
back we're being hit
as the message was relayed to captain
warren and as he remembered it
the words were come back we're being hit
though the main body moving through the
jungle was too far down the slope to get
the sounds of the fight
warren had his movement of agony had his
moment of agonized
shock and that's an interesting
tidbit a moment of agonized shock
almost as if he may have expected that
this would happen he knew kirby as
a thoroughly brave soldier
and this is the unnamed person from
from the manual too steady too seasoned
to be stampeded by a little random fire
when he called for help the thing had to
be fully desperate
the confidence between the white captain
from georgia and the negro sergeant from
california
was complete so these guys had trust
wasting not an instant warren called
back on the radio to lieutenant
robert mcclellan of first platoon
bringing up the rear
of the far stretch column get your ass
back up that hill all hands reversed and
started scrambling upward
men clutching at rocks tearing tearing
their palms on thorn vines
sliding falling and panting in desperate
effort to race up the steep
all did not fully understand the reason
why there was no attempt to observe
security
and had they been without knowing moving
into an ambush the disaster that
too soon followed could have been even
greater far above them
on the slope of hereford men who still
moved
crouched below to escape the sheet of
fire beating from all sides
most of kirby's men had died in the
first 10 minutes though he did not know
that yet
the return fire from his people grew
steadily fainter
sergeant isaac johnson a 27 year old
negro
had been sitting with a plat board at
the mortar pit when the fight began
he heard someone yell they're coming out
of the woods
in his agitation he tried to turn the
mortar around a fired up hill
not even noticing that it had been
drilled through the incoming fire was
too great and his strength too little
so he slithered up on his belly to the
left flank and dropped into a foxhole
upslope he could see 40 to 50 men at a
run
out of the trees into the elephant grass
where he lost
sight of them they were partially
camouflaged and their shirts were of all
colors
looking down hal hill he saw many more
of the enemy moving through the grass
some crawling others hunched over firing
as they moved in
it came to him as a sudden idea that he
should fire too
he thought he he thought as he fired he
had dropped at least four enemy
skirmishers with his m16
so by the way i mean we're already
talking about a
totally outnumbered force
this in one flank he sees 40 or 50 bad
guys
from the next foxhole above him pfc
henry benton
and joe l tamayo were alternately firing
up slope and downhill yelling as they
pulled the trigger johnson saw
his last of them when he ran out of
ammunition and crawled back to the
mortar pit in search of a magazine
inside the pit there were fir four men
heads down the enemy machine gun and at
least
two automatic rifles were bearing
directly
on the hole and smashing its rim johnson
could not be sure
whether the men were ducking or dead
sergeant buckaloo paul buckaloo 22 years
in the army was having his first go
in combat
the opening barrage cracked him wide
open he bolted straight across the
perimeter
vanished into the elephant grass and was
never heard from again
sergeant johnson couldn't find his spare
magazine so he picked up an m16 with 15
rounds in it
from the dead hand of sergeant edward
shepard who had no business being there
that afternoon
though he ranked kirby and might have
taken command he was overdue to be
lifted out by chopper for an appearance
before a promotion board
so he passed up the honor and died
inconspicuously from a bullet
through his brain
another longtime soldier under fire for
the first time he had stayed motionless
petrified by personal terror as
boundless as the horror exploding all
about him
his 15 bullets gone johnson crawled
toward the mortar pit screaming
come out you'll all be killed there was
no response
it was minutes too late for that the
hole held four corpses
heads bashed in by bullet fire
in the nearby hole with kirby was
another bloody welter
a rocket the russian-made p-40 round of
so
slow of motion that the eye easily
follows the trajectory came arcing in
dead center of the mark
kirby saw it in flight and yelled watch
out so did his foxhole mates
spec for austin l drummond and david s
crocker
who cried warning in the same place
split second
before any man could move the rocket
exploded just to the left of the hole
crocker died instantly from a shard that
crushed in his skull drummond took heavy
fragments in the left arm and left egg
leg such gouts of blood spouted from him
that kirby who had taken four pieces of
steel in his head but remained conscious
knew that drummond couldn't could not
last long
in physical torment drummond tried to
rise
kirby pulled at him drummond screamed
let me go i'm hurting
hurting kirby pulled him down within a
minute he died under kirby's body
blood from kirby's paint was streaming
into his eyes but the little sergeant
could still see and think he yelled to
his rto
spec four spranza call company
say i'm being hit by mortars and rockets
we gotta have gunships and ardy
spranza did his part captain warren
struggling
uphill remembered this piece of the
message coming in
we're hit by rockets and mortars
he later could later he could not recall
that sprenz had also
asked for gunfire and air artillery but
anyhow he relayed that message to the
command capsule
at lz savvy and spranza got the word
back from him
it's on the way those were his final
words
right then communication between the
company and platoon ended both radios
worked
the mass of the ridge nose intervened
and what they mean by that is these fm
radios that they're using
they work when you can see them so they
work a line of sight what we call line
of sight but if there's a
ridgeline in between you then they don't
work so whatever the terrain was they
kind of dipped down the terrain and all
of a sudden they lost communications
at that moment the front men in warren's
warren's column were halfway back to
hereford
the break off doubled warren's anxiety
though he was already doing everything
possible
he had asked that artillery be placed on
the slopes alongside the perimeter not
on hereford itself
for kirby had passed on nothing about
casualties and
warren was still thinking of 22 live men
holding the contested ground
the double time climb had begun to
slow from sheer exhaustion men stumbled
dropped in their tracks were pulled to
their feet by their mates and reeled
upwards again
warren realized now that if he continued
the pressure the company would know
would reach the scene of the fight
deadbeat
about that he no longer gave a damn
yet passing information on the radio
is so freaking important and so hard
but if you always think that you're
trying to paint a picture for the person
on the other end
you've got to think that way they don't
know what's happening
and you know if you've got casualties
and if you can give any
additional information now look i mean
obviously these guys
are in such a horrible way but that's
what's happening
that's what's happening he's he doesn't
know that anyone's been wounded he
hasn't known anyone's been killed he
thinks that they're in that position and
he's
saying hey start to put artillery on the
on the outskirts of the lz
the sounds of the struggle had not
carried to lz
savoy in the distant valley bottom the
control point was a throb partly because
of warren's call for help still more
because of the monitoring of the
conversations between eyewitnesses
who were viewing the fight from
platforms directly overhead
what they saw and what they said in no
way lessened the confusions
colonel beer so this is the interesting
thing about vietnam
is that a lot of times there would be
aircraft because they had air
superiority
for the most part and so there'd be
helicopters that would just get up
cnc helicopters command and control
and fly around and be watching this
stuff i i have a friend whose dad was in
vietnam
and he he was a silver star recipient
and the whole thing was photographed
this whole
event you know there was a a gunfight
broke out and his dad sort of
jumped into a dyke and then crawled
along and flanked the enemy and the
whole thing he had pictures the whole
thing
is but that but that tells you what it's
like
what do you got dave look i got all
sorts of things going on in my head
right now this is a brutal scene that
you're reading this
this whole thing as it's playing out and
you're describing these different things
is brutal
partially because we already know we
know the outcome and how you're
describing these little pieces
but when you're talking about the the
the inability for the and i think it's
the company commander
uh that's kind of warren warren's trying
to visualize what's going on
with with kirby in his in his platoon
when you when you as a leader get
something in your head when you kind of
create what you think is the outcome
when you
when you when you get comfortable with
what you think you know the outcome or
the situation is and you sort of
solidify
that it's really hard to change that so
if i
i picture this guy leaving and there's
so there's just complacency
slipped into all these comments that
you've read through these little pieces
of complacency of
yeah it's not gonna happen yeah i know
what's going on this is my best guy
or all those little pieces are helping
this guy warn solidify in his mind
what he thinks is is going on and it's
impossible for him
and the part that i'm connecting to in
my mind is how hard that is to for him
to visualize
things are nowhere near what you think
they are and he can't get it in his head
that this whole thing has been wiped out
his best guy's getting overrun
and when you
in your own mind predetermine the way
the outcome is going to be it makes you
so much
less flexible and adaptable and
incapable
of maneuvering the way you need to and
you know it's all in retrospect i'm just
thinking to myself
don't presume how this is gonna go yeah
it's one of the worst things you can do
and you can you can almost hear this
guy's brain
struggling trying to accept what's going
on
so it's interesting that you bring that
up and as we
start to hear more sides of this story
you got this guy warren who's
he doesn't really know he knows that his
guy is a good guy and he's calling for
help
and it says that's enough for him to
realize that there's something really
really bad
but there's a panic there's a panic of
hey
like you know if you call me and dave
you're on on the lz you call me hey jock
i need support right now
i'd be like okay hey guys listen we're
gonna start taking about
they almost immediately go into you know
go get your asses back up he literally
says get your ass back up the hill now
so there's a level of
[Music]
let's say uh urgency that he gets to
almost immediately
and as we peel this onion back
you're gonna see that you're right but
the picture that he's painted
is what's happening he knew something
was gonna go wrong
and as soon as it starts to happen he's
like could get back up there
because he didn't feel comfortable with
it it's
like you said it's just freaking awful
yeah
back to the book colonel beard the
battalion commander
major role his s3 and captain robert
offer
artillery liaison were at the brigade cp
when the news came in
they took off in a huey to view the
fight from above
this is like this is a cackworth would
get on the ground just kind of fyi just
so everybody knows
hackworth would get in the helicopter
and he land
when it made sense obviously yeah before
they could reach the scene
out of here happenstance major otto
cantrell the battalion executive officer
of 112 was already hovering above it
he had been flying in the area he'd
arrived at the opposite peak when he
heard warren's voice in the earphones
saying that a platoon was being overrun
on hereford so so warren did know that
the platoon was being overrun
at this point so he flew to station
directly above
and began orbiting low enough to see
people milling around and firing on the
ground below him
cantrell was yet too high to determine
whether they were friend or enemy
lieutenant william d fessenden
an artillery observer in another h13
had flown the same way and was circling
near cantrell he asked cantrell sir can
i bring in fire can't y'all repl replied
no i can't tell where our people are
cantrell then flew lower and at about
that time
beard the battalion commander and his
party arrived they could see
40 or more men pressing close to the
perimeter they must be vc
called beard either that replied
cantrell
or gi's with uniforms soaking wet
so this is a i know it seems crazy
to think that you couldn't tell the
difference between you know uh american
soldiers
and viet cong i'll tell you when you're
in a helicopter and you're looking at
things on the ground it is not obvious
no it's not obvious you don't need to be
miles away you can get 50 60 70 feet
away and things get
real it's really hard to tell what's
going on i i was
i learned this i was i was up at fallon
and we were calling in
helicopters to pick us up and i'm
sitting there i'm standing you know
the the terrain in fallon nevada is not
there's no trees it's just dirt
and we're standing there and the
helicopter's sitting there looking at
the helicopter it's
it's like the wind is hitting me that's
how close it is
and they can't see me yeah and i i was
just like what do you mean you can't see
me i'm waving they're like coming around
we'll come back around we can we can't
and so i had to get out the
the red smile orange smoke or whatever
yep here we are violet smoke because red
smoke wasn't merging i was thinking the
orange panel but yeah you got
some huge signal yeah well i think i
tried an orange pair
orange panel you know wasn't big enough
yeah
so that's where these guys are at back
to the book his weird his words merely
aggravated doubts all around
cantrell's trouble is that he simply
could not make himself believe that
one whole american platoon had been
wiped out
there and he was right now this is where
what you were talking about you have
this idea how could a whole american
platoon get wiped out
and it says in the book here there and
he was right and it is right
why when we'll get to this later
this american platoon the 22 guys is not
a platoon
right that's not a platoon you think of
a platoon you think of
multiple machine gunners you think of 40
guys
then he dropped to 100 feet for one
swift pass the phenomena of those few
seconds doubled his perplexity
on the ridge crest above hereford he saw
a company of men in dark suits marching
to
marking marching to this to the fire
shell fire was breaking into the landing
zone cantrell had no way of knowing that
these
were enemy rocket rounds not american
rounds coming
from other bases the dark suited men
upslope he identified his enemy he knew
that
he knew that camouflage rig which from a
distance made
made them to him look like so many
turtles
but where were the americans if not on
hereford
just then he heard a friendly voice on
his fm radio please
please you must hurry
it was spranza getting off his last
message but cantrell had no way of
knowing that either
beard viewing from the same height was
for a moment equally in the dark
from the start of the fight with good
reason kirby had forgotten casting
the correspondent he remembered only
when casting slid into his position to
ask
when are we going to get the hell out of
here kirby didn't answer
then caston said i've got to have a
weapon
and kirby silently handed him his own
357 magnum
quiet now he briefly fitted into the
hole beside
kirby he spoke only once to say sergeant
shepard is dead so now cast in the
reporter
is in the foxhole and he's got a 357
magnum
all curiosity about the thoughts of men
facing death was gone from casting he
had been eagerly questioning shepard
when the first shots were fired that
the that soldier's swift moral collapse
and sudden death
were his first shock contact with the
realities
which mocked his quest while casting's
opening words to kirby
rankled they also rang a bell almost
anywhere seemed to be better than the
exposed ground to which the survivors
clutched
now under a dust paul kicked up by the
grazing fire
the fight had been going somewhere
between 20 and 25 minutes and the fire
was fastly becoming wholly one-sided
next to kirby's position the enemy
skirmishers crawling through the
elephant grass were not more than 15
feet away the fire buildup suggested
they were bunching probably for a rush
kirby saw them fleetingly and vaguely as
through a haze
the flash of an arm of the bobbing of a
head kirby got off three hand grenades
in that direction as rapidly as he could
throw
the explosion seemed to damp the
close-up fire but not for more than 60
seconds
in this moment of decision kirby did not
doubt that the ring
had been closed and that all the
skirmishers waited on the lower slope
amid the tall elephant grass
between him and the company poised for
the kill so he's sitting there thinking
okay we're surrounded
and i know the company's down the hill
but there's there's bad guys in between
us
still he yelled out let's make it with
that he rolled out of his hole and down
the slope caston
jumped from the hole just ahead of him
and was running upright and in the clear
pfc bob taste and spec 4 av
spikes from the foxhole above kirby went
past kirby
one rolling the other sprinting then
spranza dashed by him
as he rolled kirby thought he glimpsed
isaac johnson
off to his left firing two m16s
he was wrong about that johnson had
heard someone not quite echoing kirby
shout moved down the hill his own weapon
was empty he paused briefly to pick up
another only to find it in like
condition
kirby had seen him in that fleeting
second when he clutched two useless
pieces
before throwing them both aside
johnson's face was already a bloody mask
from three superficial grenade wounds
such was his tension he neither heard
the blast of the grenade nor
knew that he had been hurt now in panic
because he was unarmed he made a running
dive at the rocky embankment giving him
getting him off hereford lower's side
then he rolled on and on down slope till
his body could take no more beating
in that spinning descent he covered 150
meters of
rock strewn trail
when and where he stopped a twisting
v-shaped cleft in the ridge back
gave off to the left along this slit
that trickled the stream no wider than
the palm of johnson's hand
he crawled into the bed of it 20 yards
or so to where the jungle growth stopped
him
then he gathered bushes and vines down
around him and lay with his face flat in
the water
so he's hiding dove off a freaking cliff
fell down 150 meters and now he's hiding
in this little ravine
not too far above him the ordeal of the
other few survivors continued to grow
worse
of this johnson felt and remembered
nothing thought
paralyzed by the grip of exhaustion he
had closed his mind to the sounds
getting out separately some running
others rolling kirby's men had stayed
that way during the first few yards of
flight
through the short grass just off the lz
coming to the rocky steep
they began to converge toward the center
whence the trail ran
downhill it is always so with men
against fire
fear and herd instinct brings them
together which is the worst
which is the worst thing that can happen
since it just shapes up a broad target
spranza was the first to get it as they
approached the steep
kirby's still rolling others crawling
casting standing
i'm hit spranza yelled and screamed like
a panther
three bullets one in each leg and one in
the head but marvelously
he still lived and now he was erect and
walking
castin the reporter yelled back hell
everybody's hit that was news to the
others
casting had taken a bullet in one arm
and several grenade frags in the back
saying nothing
in his last moments the correspondent
had the courage of a lion
here was a man and they knew it
spikes yelled i'm hit it was a bullet
through the right arm
they then moved 20 feet down the rock
bank when spranza yelled again
hold it up there in front of us
expecting it would come
kirby froze right where he was casting
kept moving in long strides
straight to the trail which led downhill
through the elephant grass
he had made up his mind and kirby did
not bother to shout a warning
standing clear on the on the trail was
an enemy shoulder
soldier rifle aimed kirby heard a scream
as caston went down
though casting was not 15 yards from him
he could not see the fall as the body
was enveloped by the sea of grass
he heard the whack of the bullet and the
thump of the body the bullet had drilled
casting
through his left temple casting's
personal effect were looted as soon
after he fell
the camera films and purse were later
recovered from the bodies of the enemy
in the fight that soon followed many of
the next of kin
get not even that grain of comfort it is
an agonizing matter for the commanders
having to explain why the dead soldiers
most prized possessions
and pictures cannot be returned
kirby could now hear enemy soldiers
moving up slope
toward him they're chattering the clang
of metal
from their weapons being worked he was
down on his haunches
and so were spranza spikes and taste
none was firing
their only thought was to hide in the
grass which rose two feet
taller than a standing man they all knew
taste was slowly dying
two bullets in his neck multiple mortar
shards in his back
though conscious he made no complaint
only asking for water
of which there was none the skirmishers
were moving up now and beating the grass
on both sides of them
kirby saw seven of them coming right
toward him not 10 feet away
and he knew he was discovered he still
held an m79 grenade launcher
so did spikes they fired right together
and the blast killed five of the enemy
the other two crawled away leaving blood
trails
another skirmisher closed in from the
left spraying the ground between them
with automatic pistol
kirby had his m-79 crooked in his arm he
had just taken another bullet through
the right wrist and was feeling the
wound the skirmisher came on and looked
through the grass straight at them
spikes fired his m79 the range was so
short that the grenade didn't arm
but the sheer velocity it blew the man's
head off
had it armed it would have likely killed
both spikes and kirby
a second vc closed in from the left only
to turn his back as he almost stumbled
over them
kirby killed him at a range of five feet
together two more groups closed in on
them from the right and left
kirby took two hand grenades from
spranza who by now was wholly down
and throwing them in both directions
with his wounded arm he drove them off
he had no impression of how many he had
killed or whether he had
even scored a hit he simply knew that
they had faded back
easing the immediate pressure
momentarily
while this deadly hide-and-seek game
went on down slope
hereford lz was being pounded by 105 and
155 millimeter howitzers
from the valley basis colonel beard had
called for it from his perch aloft and
still
earlier when early when warren asked for
it
whether it might have been brought in
sooner and done any good is an open
question there was no right
moment for its use until the americans
and cleared away which movement could
only be guessed at
now it had come and the perimeter was
being cratered
one of the effects was to drive more of
the enemy to the grass
field lower down where kirby and his
mates
crouched the game was still on from down
slope a machine gun
opened fire and skyed the grass beside
them kirby went flat in the nick of time
and the bullets zinged directly over his
head
spikes didn't make it one burst caught
him in the head
the sound was enough kirby two feet from
him didn't have to look to know he was
dead
and he did not wish to look
kirby crawled down slope about 10 feet
now looking for a weapon
thinking that the enemy might have
dropped one no luck he was wholly out of
ammunition
and had no arm left but a flare pistol
so he lay flat on his back wondering
what to do another skirmisher came
back came up parted the grass and looked
directly down on him
kirby rolled over on his side in the
same motion fired his flare pistol
upward
the round smashed into the glaring face
not three feet above him
getting him right between the eyes the
body was spun completely over by the
blast
with the figure kicking kirby did not
wait to see more than that
he crawled back the way he had come to
get spranza the impulse was that if he
had to die
he would rather not be alone both men
were silent now
there was nothing to say time had about
run out
they thought they were the only
survivors though this they were slightly
wrong
johnson was still face down in his
private cleft spec 4
charles stuckey whose swift reaction had
started the fight
had moved obliquely to the others in
getting away from the perimeter
hidden in the tall grass alongside the
knob he had rare fortune
until the final minutes he came under a
grenade shower
the last of the survivors to get hit
directly towards kirby and spranza
another enemy group moved down the slope
kirby didn't wait for them having
nothing to fire he crawled upward
through
the elephant grass leaving sprans and
passing the skirmishers undetected
they fairly stumbled across spranza he
played dead
his head being gory from a bullet that
had entered his left ear and emerged
through his nose
it is less remarkable that the deception
worked than that he stayed conscious and
was
capable of thought they rolled him over
searched his pockets took his wallet
knife and cigarettes and continued on
having gone inert spranza stayed that
way
kirby had no sense of the barraging of
hereford
though the fire had been going on all of
ten minutes now as he crawled upward he
heard
at last heard the explosions and knew
what they were that determined him he
would crawl
to the fire and try and hug it two
thoughts were in his mind
charlie will get as far away from this
as possible and if he had to die
that was still the preferable risk
halfway back to the perimeter his ear
told him that the shelling had suddenly
ceased
not knowing what that meant he still
crawled on it was a tortured
most labored movement as his last
reserve of will and strength was
draining away
he got within six feet of the first
foxhole before he looked up
what he saw almost numbed his senses and
he felt
as as if he would faint
sitting in the foxhole pointing an m16
directly at his head
was pfc morgan of first platoon
he crawled a few more feet forward still
prone looked around every hole at
hereford
was occupied by an american captain
warren and the company had returned to
the hill
sergeant owen l lewis and james w
edwards came over to help kirby to his
feet no words passed between them
they were not merely choked up they were
sobbing convulsively
and seeing them kirby knew tears for the
first time that day
later warren said if my men cried it was
because they were so
damn mad kirby knew better than that
they were moaning mourning the death of
the platoon
kirby told them where to look for sprans
and not knowing that the company had
found him on the way up or that he'd
already been evacuated from hereford by
the chopper
stuckey appeared about that moment and
he and kirby were flown to on k aboard
the same huey
it was some time later that johnson came
in when the hill went quiet he started
crawling upward
coming to the tall grass he saw his
friend sergeant wallace w
hood standing in the clear on the
forward edge of hereford
and that sight brought him to his feet
days later he was still in a state of
shock
kirby taken to the hospital of his own
choice returned to the company duty
within ten days still convalescent
unlike johnson he was fully coherent
with his emotions under tight control
until he spoke of seeing the company in
tears
warren and the company had made that
frantic uphill climb to hereford in
exactly 35 minutes
the descent over the same trail had
taken them an hour longer
if a record march it was too little a
veil they saw dead americans in all but
six
fox foxholes and thought at first
spranza was the only survival
survivor the platoon weapons had been
taken
everybody had been stripped of personal
effects
warren deployed two of his platoons for
a 600-yard sweep to the eastward along
both flanks of the ridge
the hunt proved almost barren of result
though blood trails were numerous and
heavily marked
only five bodies were found and they all
too obviously had been felled by
artillery
the fanatics must have hauled away a
larger count of dead
than was lost to the company
so in the end they departed as they had
come more suddenly
than mysteriously how the trap had been
sprung was easy enough to figure out in
retrospect
retrospect this enemy force of about 200
was much too fresh to have followed in
along warren's wake
as he came over the trail from hill 766.
the time interval was not long enough to
have permitted ascent from lower levels
toward which warren had kept moving if
there had been an assembly and movement
still
no sound had been detected last the
enemy's main weapons
were sighted dead on target
thus the enemy force must have been
there all the time
some yards off the trail and along the
ridge sides
as warren's column had walked through
had warren stayed in full strength on
hereford there might not have been
no fight he carried out his orders
of that came the most melancholy episode
in operation crazy horse
now you may have noticed
that i didn't mention the author of this
book that i'm reading
and the reason i didn't mention the
author of this book is because i
didn't want to cloud your
impression the author
was a guy by the name of sla marshall
and i talked about him on
podcast 142 where
we covered his book men against fire and
you heard him use that
phrase in here and
sla marshall was a famous
military man we'll say and he ended up
be
being a general he was a historian
he was a writer he was a he was a
reservist so he was a civilian writer
and wrote a bunch of articles
and it was work for a newspaper but he's
also a very controversial figure
and and hackworth tour did a tour with
him in vietnam
and kind of reveals the guy's character
he was very egotistical
and he also he also made claims
about his experiences in war that were
not true he he lied about his experience
you know he he lied about his uh
military about his combat experience in
world war one
and then he also wrote in a way
that supported his own theories and his
own hypotheses
and you know in men against fire there's
a lot of people that went back and
broke down what he wrote in that book
and we covered that book on this podcast
like i said
because we didn't want to throw away the
the baby with the bathwater
but there's a lot of things that were
very controversial and some of them just
straight up wrong and on top of all that
he never let the truth get in the way of
a good story
so when i read this portion of battles
in the monsoon
this was this was on my mind and
the article i mean th this book
didn't it didn't paint kirby in such a
bad light
as this as the as the manual did
which made him just sound like a
complete you know
lackadaisical guy that just let all the
stuff go and and didn't have any
discipline and didn't follow any good
protocols
but at the same time i'm reading this
book thinking well you know
sla marshall he's not necessarily a guy
that's gonna he just wants a really good
story so he's not in my opinion
and just based on the things he's
written in the past this isn't some this
isn't a reliable source either
even though he would go and interview
people like those quotes he's getting he
would
interview people absolutely but still
he's gonna he's gonna make that story
kind of the way he wants it and
so i was still not satisfied with the
information that i had in front of me
and so i did some more research
and i found another article i found an
article on a
on a website called historynet.com
and there's an article written by a guy
named michael christie
michael christie so michael christie
enlisted in the marine corps out of high
school
and then he joined the army yeah became
an officer probably went to college
became an officer served in the fifth
special forces group in vietnam from
1967 to 1968
and in 1970 he was the commander
of sea company 1st battalion 12th
cavalry regiment
the very same company involved in the
battle at lz hereford so he wasn't there
but
you know you're gonna have some
connections you're gonna be able to put
some things together you're gonna hear
some
some backfill and he
eventually retired and became a writer
and he produced a bunch of documentaries
and
then he made a series of leadership
videos for for the military
so the military hired him to make
leadership videos
some of those were hosted by lee marvin
which is pretty cool
but he wrote this article
and this article is called last
stand at lz hereford
soldiers shield themselves as best they
can from the dirt
and debris stirred up by a huey
squeezing into
tight one ship landing zone around noon
the pilot touches down and two officers
jump from the helicopter and land in a
large
mud puddle one gi chuckles
pokes his buddy and laughs quietly at
the officers
in fresh jungle fatigues stamping the
mud off their polished boots
a dirty unshaven captain greets them
wearing torn jungle fatigues and mud
covered boots toting an m16 so there's
warren
so now we're starting to get a little
better picture you know you've got
the stereotypical sort of officers
rolling in
with their brand new fatigues and
polished boots and outcomes
warren who's been out in the jungle now
for a while on this just this operation
the trio moves to the edge of the
landing zone where towering elephant
grass offers a bit of protection
from the early afternoon sun the major
unfolds a map and the three begin
discussing a mission within minutes
there is strong disagreement over the
plan
lieutenant colonel rutland beard
commander of the first battalion 12th
cavalry
first cavalry division and his
operations officer major william roll
are insisting that captain don warren
charlie company commander leave his
20-man mortar platoon
alone on landing zone hereford to
provide fire support
to warren's company as it moves down the
steep precipice
toward the valley below
warren is equally insistent on
keeping at least one rifle squad behind
to provide security
sir my mortar platoon is down to half
strength because of malaria
and has only m16s and a couple m79s
if i leave behind a rifle squad they
will have at least one machine gun for
security
beard tells warren that the mortar
platoon will be on the hill for less
than an hour before it will be lifted
out and taken to another lz
warren's eyes lock on beards anything
can happen in hours sir
irritated at warren's near
insubordination
beard warns captain if you don't do as i
order you will be in more trouble than
you can imagine
is that understood warren hesitates a
moment before answering tersely
yes colonel will that be all sir
beard indicates yes and warren spins on
his heels and walks over to his rifle
platoon leaders to pass the orders
beard takes a sideward glance at roll
shakes his head
and returns to his helicopter
so automatically we see where this is
going
and by the way look i love this book uh
the the
the the squad leader makes a difference
but the squad leader is getting put in a
bad situation right now
yeah warren has every reason for concern
about the safety of his under strength
mortal platoon hereford's topography
makes it nearly impossible for
even a fully armed rifle company to
defend it from a determined enemy
it is a small saddle 165 yards
long by 45 yards wide that's partially
encircled by
tall elephant grass beyond the elephant
grass is completely surrounded by rugged
unforgiving landscape the most
hostile being the steep razorback
ridgeline reaching northeast
toward a towering mountain or nearly a
thousand feet high at the base of the
ridge
hereford's northern boundary begins to
slope gently downhill
continues on explaining what we already
know hereford is also the center
of fierce fighting that began seven days
earlier on may 15. so now they give a
little background
to this this whole operation crazy horse
when word of that battle filtered down
to first cavalry leaders they then
decided the next day to conduct a major
operation in the area
and that's what they're doing sitting on
the edge of his foxhole
on lz hereford staff sergeant robert
kirby
watches as captain warren leads three
platoons from his rifle company off the
mountain and down a steep slope in
search of the enemy
when the last man disappears over the
rim kirby checks his watch it's 1 40 p.m
less than in less than 45 minutes his
mortar platoon is to be airlifted
off hereford to lz savoy where it will
continue
providing fire support for charlie
company
to occupy a company size defensive
perimeter with only 19 men
so now we're talking companies to size
perimeter that's that's 150 people
yeah he's got 19 guys
kirby figured the best way to do this
was to form a u-shaped defense
and place two men into every third
foxhole this however
left the top of the horseshoe open
knowing his men are spread too thin
kirby a 29 year old native of south los
angeles scans the perimeter from his
foxhole
at the bend of the hershey beginning
with the gun crew directly behind him
inside the pit is sergeant charles
gaines
and spec 4 austin drummond a former
golden gloves champion
with fast hands perfect for dropping
rounds into a mortar tube sergeant isaac
johnson sits on the ground nearby with a
plot board on his lap
the gun crew is ready to place
supporting fire when and where the
company commander
needs it most of the mortar platoon have
been together since fort benning georgia
but a few are replacements who have
never been in battle so kirby
has no idea how well they will react
under fire one of his new
men is spec for david crocker
a 21 year old medic who sits a few feet
from kirby reading a paperback
his medical bag ready at his side and
the foxhole next to kirby is long-time
radio operator spec for john spranza
who is the platoons linked to the
outside world and is never more than an
arm's length away from kirby
communications are unreliable because
the high mountain's in deep valley
how's the como ask kirby so far so good
answer spranza
but who knows for how long kirby focuses
on the western section of the perimeter
holding down the most forward position
at the top of the open horseshoe
are two men who have fought bravely in
previous fire fights
private's lonnie sleepy williams whose
deep sleep
often resulted in heavy snoring and
clearance gomer braim
a good-natured hillbilly who looked and
acted
like tv's gomer pyle
two empty fighting positions below them
are
combat vets robert radar roader
and pfc harold mack jr in a fierce
firefight a few months
before kirby had been wounded and pinned
down
when 18 year old roeder ignoring heavy
fire ran
out and pulled him to safety mack and
rotor have been close friends ever since
airborne school so we didn't know that
about
kirby that kirby's bidding combat he's
been wounded and he's
still out there doing his job this guy
has combat experience and now we're
gonna think that he's just gonna be
laxatical in this scenario
in the last defensive position on the
western side kirby assigned a competent
and respected leader
sergeant louis buckley with pfc henry
benton who joined the platoon only two
weeks ago kirby knows little about
benton
and the two new privates covering the
southern sector a few yards away from
kirby's position
joel tamayo and james francis brooks jr
both of whom joined the platoon just a
few weeks earlier so he's got those guys
that he doesn't really know too well
kind of close at hand
kirby decides to walk the eastern side
of the perimeter but before he goes he
tells buckley to collect and stack water
cans food containers and other equipment
in preparation for the helicopter pickup
roger that sarge says buckley as he
springs into action
as kirby walks away he hears spranza
take call
take the first call for reconnaissance
fire in advance of the company's
movement
in the valley below so why is kirby
walking the perimeter because he's doing
his job as a leader
and he's also prepping to leave because
you when you when you when the
helicopters come in
is it that the good time to stack up
stuff and get it off the dz
or the lz no you want to have it prepped
so the helicopters don't spend a bunch
of time there
and you want to get all the stuff off
the lz so the enemy can't use it
sitting in the nearest position to kirby
kirby's on the eastern sector is
spec for av spikes who is complaining
about something to pfc
wade taste spike stop bitching and keep
your eyes open
warns kirby as he approaches
spike's a 26-7 year veteran whose
disregard for authorities well known
looks at kirby but says nothing kirby
orders 18 year old taste to help buckley
who's already picking up scattering cans
and containers so he's tell stop
bitching and keep your eyes open this is
what a
platoon sergeant should be doing kirby
moves to the next position where look
magazine correspondent sam caston is
interviewing spec for daniel post
and pfc roger robert benjamin caston
came out of the field a day before to
write a story about
death he had chosen to stay on hereford
with a mortal platoon rather than travel
the company post
known as platoon's practical joker feeds
cast in mischievous responses while
benjamin only responds in yes or no
answers
kirby queries the two troopers on what
they will do if attacked they tell them
they plan on throwing hand grenades down
the rocky preposition below their
position and firing
interlocking fires with the positions on
their left and right
so that's kirby kirby's like okay what
are you gonna do if we get hit they say
we're gonna throw grenades over there
everybody got interlocking
fields of fire with this other position
satisfied kirby heads
for the most forward position at the top
of the eastern sector
sector manned by paul harrison and
charles stuckey both battle tested
specialists
harrison and stuckey have established
interlocking fields of fire across the
open end of the ushi perimeter
with williams and braim on the western
side
so he set the positions he went out
inspect the position to make sure
people understand their field of fire
squad leaders
actually doing his job on the way back
to his position kirby knives nods to
sergeant first class edward shepherd
sitting on the rim of the foxhole not
far apart from the mortar pit shepherd
38 is the only soldier there who's not
in the mortar platoon
he stayed behind to catch a helicopter
where he is a
to appear before a promotion board kirby
sits on the edge of the foxhole and
watches spranza talking on the radio
with captain warren who is calling
correction on where to place another
mortar round
spranza yells back correction to the gun
crew and it then fires a few more rounds
shortly after 2 pm
warren radio spranza that the
helicopters are on the way and
that word spreads from hold the hole
what warren does not know is that the
helicopters are actually delayed
and still sitting on the ground at lz
savvy
in the valley around 2 15 five minutes
before the anticipated arrive in the
helicopter
stuckey spots three well-camouflaged
north vietnamese army soldiers
watching him from the elephant grass he
opens fire with his m16 and harrison
joins in
the three enemy drop either dead or
wounded so
you're if you don't catch well
camouflaged
nva if you're not paying attention these
guys are paying attention
then in the next instant a massive
volume of automatic fire and small arms
fires unleashed from the high ground to
the north and a ravine to the east
shepherd sitting on the rim of the
foxhole is killed in the first valley
volley within seconds the rocket
propelled grenades mortar rounds explode
near each occupied position
men bro deep inside their foxhole under
the terrifying shrapnel slicing through
the air and bullets
cracking overhead the platoon is
surrounded outmanned and outgunned
kirby yells as friends at a radio warren
and tell them they are under attack and
need
immediate air and artillery support a
stunned warren acknowledges
immediately calls battalion for fire
support and orders his company to turn
around and head back up the hill
so to your point earlier warren
the reason he was able to turn around
and head
and go is because he didn't even want to
leave in the first place
in the open stacking equipment taste
falls to the ground with two bullets to
the throat
buckley his shoulder covered in blood
dashes across the open perimeter
screaming get off the hill get off the
hill and disappears into the elephant
grass
harrison yells for stucky to go to the
mortar pit while he stays behind to hold
off the enemy
stuckey takes a few more shots at the
enemy turns and zigzags
for the mortar pit when an rpg round
explodes in front of him throwing him to
the ground
after the shrapnel and dirt stop falling
he raises his head and looks to see
where post and benjamin
had been trying to make an escape both
are dead
he sprints towards a large large rock
right just outside the perimeter as he
turns
the corner of it he encounters an enemy
soldier about to throw a grenade into
the lz
spotting stucky the nva tosses the
grenade directly at him it's den
instead the grenade sails over stuck his
head hits the rock behind him and
explodes
wounding him managing to stay in his
feet stuck he fires three rounds in the
nva's chest
killing him instantly stuck he then
moves around the rock face finds a
narrow crevice and squeezes into it
hidden from the enemy paul harrison
slapping magazine after magazine into
his rifle fires at every charging enemy
soldier he can see
when he runs out of ammunition he jumps
up from his foxhole
and charges the nva using his m16 as a
club
cracking a few heads before the blood
covered rifle slips from his hands
he then wades into the enemy with his
fists until he falls
dead from dozens of bullets
as north vietnamese burst through the
elephant grass
spranza opens up with his m16 on full
automatic
tearing three of them apart
he manages to fire off a few more shots
before rtb rounds
rbg rounds visible in their slow
trajectory plunge toward the mortar pit
one round slams in front of spranza's
foxhole showering his back with shrapnel
another explodes to his left killing doc
crocker instantly
the third round sends shrapnel into
kirby's arms head and chest
the last round hits the rear lip of the
mortar pit tearing off drubbin's right
arm and mangling his left leg
he dies in a pool of blood
gaines is killed with a bullet through
his head
johnson the only gun crew member alive
takes shrapnel in the face but continues
firing on the advancing enemy
as attackers fall others jump over them
running toward
johnson who keeps firing until he is out
of ammunition
he makes a running dive at the rocky
abatement on hereford southern edge
and rolls down the slope careening off
rocks and over tree roots until finally
coming to a stop
he spots a v-shaped depression hidden in
thick vegetation
with a stream running through it he
pulls himself into the stream and
gathers brush and vines to hide his body
grip with fear and exhaustion
on the western perimeter williams and
brain frantically fire their m16s on
full automatic at the waves of nva
as do rotor and mack a few nva fall dead
but most brave the wall of fire
overrunning the position and killing
williams and braim before turning
toward rotor and mack mack pops up to
get a better shot when he takes a bullet
to the head crumbling back into the
foxhole dead
roeder fires his m79 until he's out of
ammunition
then picks up max m16 and continues
firing until it too is empty
he throws two grenades at the charging
enemy forcing them to fall back then
jumps out of his fighting position
and heads for benton's foxhole when he
tumbles in he finds benton dead
he crawls out and with bullets trailing
his every step races over to the foxhole
of brooks and tamayo but they are dead
as well
the western defense has crumbled
figuring everyone else is dead
roeder does what he is trained to do
escape and evade
he tears down the side of the hill into
the elephant grass followed by several
enemy
with bullets zipping over his head he
runs deeper into the elephant grass as
fast as he can
until he's overcome by exhaustion and
drops to the ground
when he is gasping when his gasping for
air subsides he realize the enemy is no
longer following him
he stays hidden silently praying that he
will be spared
still in his hole spranza sees a figure
running toward his position
he fires off a quick burst somehow
missing his target
don't shoot for god's sake it's me sam
caston screams as he drops into the
foxhole
the reporter looks over at kirby and
yells we need to get the hell out of
here
kirby shouts back where we're surrounded
get six on the horn kirby tells spranza
tell him to hurry or we're dead spranza
screams into the headset please hurry
we're being overrun but warren doesn't
get the transmission as communication
between herefor and the company no
longer exists
sprans returns to the artillery
frequency and repeats the message
that artillery rto passes the call to
warren who now pushes his company even
more ordering his men to double time up
the hill
a murderous pace in the mud and tangled
vines
by this time the battalion executive
officer major cantrell
is circling above hereford and his
observation helicopter and colonel beard
is watching the battle from his command
and control
huey the swarm of enemy they see below
is so intermingled with the mortar
position neither officer can distinguish
who's who
rather than kill the defenders by
mistake beard holds off on artillery
requested by kirby
meanwhile kirby sees four enemy crawling
towards his position less than 15 feet
away and tosses three hand grenades as
fast as he can stopping their advance
kirby now realizes casting is right
their only chance for survival is to get
off the lz
he cups his hands to bark the order when
the badly wounded taste suddenly drops
into his foxhole
kirby ties a dressing on tastes bleeding
throat and yells over the enemy fire
we gotta make a break for it call
already on the hill
spranza reaches the artillery net
shouting into the handset
we're getting out of here the place is
covered with enemy just about everybody
is dead he is told
artillery is on hold
with bullets kicking up dirt all around
them kirby and taste
low crawl over to spranza and caston
we'll go over the rim in the direction
the company will be coming in hollers
kirby
let's go as spranza struggles with his
radio while he climbs out of the foxhole
kirby screams forget the radio blow it
spranza pulls the pin of a hand grenade
and throws it in the foxhole with the
radio
the three soldiers in casting move as
quickly away from the blast
and a few steps later come across a
wounded wounded av
spikes clutching his m79 kirby and
spranza have their m16s but very little
ammunition
castin who is also wounded has a 357
magnum that kirby gave him
taste is unarmed the five wounded men
now move
toward the slope descending into a deep
ravine to the east
kirby tastes spikes and cast and run
crawl and roll
into the elephant grass while spranza
act as a rear guard
before rolling down the hill to join
them
as they reach a small ravine they hear
the enemy coming down from the lz in hot
pursuit they lie down figuring the
americans are hiding
the nva began beating the grass the
first north vietnamese to spot the
americans is shot in the face by spranza
kirby kills another standing nearby
spikes fires his m79 into the group
killing five the other two crawl away
wounded
seconds later another group of north
vietnamese spray the ground
around the americans sprans it takes
three bullets in his right leg one
smashing into his kneecap
severing the tendon another bullet rips
through his left leg
i'm hit sprans the screams as he falls
into a hepa on the jungle floor
kirby sprays the advancing enemy with
the last of his ammunition causing them
to retreat
when he bends down to check on sprans a
bullet smashes into his right arm
he's now losing blood from many wounds
kirby eyes an nva
peeking over the grass and pulls out a
rusty french flare gun he'd found on an
old battlefield and fires hitting in
between the eyes
the soldier falls backwards screaming in
agony as his flesh burns away
in the meantime taste silently bleeds to
death from his throat wounds
hearing something behind him spranza
spins around just as a bullet enters the
back of his skull
travels through his jaw and exes out of
his nose tearing away the cartilage
teeth
tissue and skin eyes filled with blood
spranza goes down badly wounded but
somehow still alive
possibly to regroup the enemy stops
firing kirby tells everyone to head
farther down the ravine
quietly the forward survivors crawl then
walk down the slope
with help from kirby and spike spranza
manages to keep up
feeling somewhat safe with a nva about a
hundred yards behind they move a little
faster
suddenly spotting a small group of enemy
coming up a trail to their flank
spranzel signals to get down
casting does not see spranza's warning
and keeps going
running straight into a group of north
vietnamese coming from another direction
one of the nva shoots casting in the
head killing him
the enemy now opens fire to the grasses
from two sides
spikes takes several bullets in his
chest kirby checks his pulse but cannot
find one
the north vietnamese troops slowly
weighed through the grass toward kirby
and spranza
kirby's out of ammo sprans rifle is
jammed but he has two grenades left and
he gives them to kirby who tosses them
into the advancing enemy
just then friendly artillery rounds
begin
pounding lz hereford the deafening
explosion stopped the enemies advance
kirby and spranza take advantage of the
situation and begin to move
slowly back up the hill but it's too
much for spranza
go without me he gasps i can't move any
further i'm dying
i'm not leaving you alone says kirby
go now spransy yell save yourself i've
made peace with my lord
just go
kirby believing spranza will die for
sure reluctantly recedes to the rto's
demand and crawls away
back towards hereford
spranza although growing weaker from
loss of bud blood
finds the will to take off a scabbard
knife strapped to his leg
by a leather thong he places the knife
around
on the ground next to him uses a the
rawhide as a tourniquet to stop the
bleeding in his right leg
he then somehow manages to open his
first aid kit find a gauze bandage and
begins wrapping around
his head and eye before he can finish
however he hears rustling of men coming
toward him through the grass
he takes his knife into his hand and
rolls over face down in the dirt
playing dead spranza doesn't move a
muscle as three or four nva
slowly approach he smells their bodies
and stale breath as they search him for
anything of value
one man turns him over and roughly
strips off his signet ring
another's take his wallet cigarettes and
dog tags
unable to stay motionless another second
he's about to jump up with his knife
when he hears a helicopter rapidly
descending it sprays the ground with
bullets
some so close they spattered dirt in his
face screaming frantically
the nva run for cover
still afraid to move spranza continues
to play dead and seconds later he hears
someone carefully moving toward him
he grips his knife a little tighter and
when he feels a hand grab his shoulder
he musters all the strength he has left
and tries stabbing the man
but the large shattery figure bat licked
by the sun
drifting through the trees quickly grabs
spranza's knife
in hand screaming hey it's me carlos
carlos cruz
charlie company had made it back up the
hill
the last of his energy drained spranza
lays down his head and slips into
unconsciousness
kirby is halfway up the slope when
friendly artillery ceases falling
uncertain what it means he keeps
crawling his many wounds are taking
their toll but he keeps going until he
reaches the top of the hill where he
sees
charlie company troops everywhere
unable to control his wounded body and
freight emotions he slides to the ground
a medic
gives him a shot of morphine and stops
his bleeding
when the wounded stuckey comes crawling
into the lz another medic rushes over
lays him down and treats his wounds
sprans is carried up the hill in a
stretcher made from ponchos and shortly
he kirby and stuckey
are placed in a medevac helicopter and
flown out
passing the medevacs flying out
helicopters begin delivering
reinforcements
who pile out onto hereford
a look of horror passes over their faces
at the sight of so much death and
destruction
one soldier throws up
hearing the helicopters coming and going
johnson who got off the hill
and evaded the enemy slowly approaches
the lz only to face the muzzle of an m16
held by pfc morgan he drops to the
ground
out of relief when he is recognized by
morgan
the last mortar platoon survivor to get
back to the lz is a dazed
roader company platoon leader asked
rogan to identify the bodies
all of which have been stripped of
personal effects and shot in the head
he is able to name a few before the
weight of the massacre takes its toll
he cannot look at another dead friend
as he sits down the afternoon monsoon
rains begin pouring down
out of the dark sky
rotor shivers as the rain pelts his
sobbing body
so much death in such a small place
so there's another view of this battle
and clearly
you know the the difference is immense
the leadership issues
you know there's a whole discussion to
have about that
you know at what point when you're being
told to do something that doesn't make
sense at what point do you
at what point do you say we're not doing
that and and you know this is leadership
strategy and tactics and they got
the whole assessment of that and it's
not like i'm not saying leadership and
strategy and tactics tells you the
answer
but it gives you the the options
and it's heavy options to weigh and and
you could look at warren and say well if
that if it wasn't safe i wouldn't do it
okay well then he fires you on the spot
he puts some young lieutenant in charge
of the platoon
and you get thrown on the helicopter and
taken out so so what good did you do
now you could also say hey roger that
by the way give me a give me a fire team
over here give me a gun give me a
machine gunner this is what we're doing
once the once the boss leave you could
do that it's a good option i like that
option
you could and you don't know what kind
of relationship we have
because there's also i mean i guess we
could say that
it appears that the relationship isn't
great i guess we do know that much
but sometimes if somebody is very
convicted in the way that they're
offering advice
it can be convincing and this is
something that i have to be careful of
because i know i can be convincing i
know i can't be
and i have to be careful in fact that's
one of the probably the original
reasons for me being such a listener
is i know that if i say i think we
should do this a lot of people just say
roger that like if that's what you think
we're on board i mean
that's kind of something i had to watch
out for and it be turned me into more of
a listener because i didn't want to
subdue people's thoughts i didn't want
to tamper with their ideas
and i didn't want to to override
how they thought something should go so
we have to be careful of that as a
leader to make sure that we aren't just
being so
overbearing that people don't push back
against us
the three different versions i get if
you want to call them versions just
three different perspectives right of
that
you know paint each one paints such a
unique picture
and you know i wrote down on my notes
again everything
that i write down or just the things
that i'm thinking in real time and and
it's really frustrating to sit here and
listen to this knowing the outcome and
seeing
all these pieces play out knowing
that this was a totally this was this
was a preventable this is a leadership
failure it is a leadership failure at a
lot of different levels and this last
one
really paints a more clear picture of
how this
predicament happened but knowing that
this is this is not an
unsolvable problem that they were just
in no way could this have been prevented
this is simply not true and and the
frustration of that
and when i when i picture just the
conversation of the
of the person in charge telling a
subordinate
do it or else just the just the
the philosophy that i lead through my
authority
and the catastrophic events that happen
that has
in this case we're talking human life i
mean this is a
a catastrophic thing but those same
that same approach and how often leaders
are emphatic in what they want
not recognizing just how destructive
that is to them
as a leader and i'm sitting here trying
to picture these guys up in a helicopter
looking down
and the sickening feeling they must have
had of this is what i
what what did i create how did i how did
this happen
well it happened because of you because
you as a leader
demanded things happen the way that you
want
and i'm picturing while i mean and i was
struggling early with this guy with
with the company commander not being
able to
reconcile and that's just me piecing
things together and and i imagine this
feeling of
the entire time walking down the hill
knowing knowing he didn't want to do
that
the patent quote front line
the front line the leader in the field
is always right right you're coming from
your helicopter you're getting off and
you're telling me what to do
that just sits so foul for me
and the other thing that's interesting
about this is you would think
that we could be sitting here saying as
two you know
military leaders that you and i were
you you you it's it's very easy to say
we could you and i could be sitting here
having a conversation
where look discipline is paramount
obviously we could sit here and say
jocko
jack was saying discipline is paramount
no one would question that for one
millisecond
discipline is paramount you have to you
have to get people
into a point where they will obey what
you say
and you they need to do it that's what
military training is that's what you
learn in boot camp that's what you learn
in officer candidate school
to to instant obey orders like that's
what we want
and that's just just so wrong it's just
so wrong it's so wrong to think that
it's so wrong to feel that way
and you know what like i'm so
thankful that
i had the luxury of being in the
military and being
able to experience this and and then on
top of that getting to see it while i
was training people and then on top of
it getting to see it with all these
companies that we work with
because occasionally to this day
someone will say to me somebody at some
company will say
yeah but sometimes don't they just need
to shut up and do what they're told to
do
i get that i get that i still get that
and what they think i'm gonna say is
well hell yeah that's what everybody
thinks i'm gonna say
and it's like actually no you don't want
that
and i actually i actually had a good uh
situation like this was working with a
client
and i had two people on the call there's
more than two people but there's two
people that
kind of rose to the conversation one of
them was
you know but they just need to do it and
and i rebutted that guy
and said well if what you're going to do
is just you know bark
to him shut up and do it whether you
believe it or not that's not going to
have a good outcome and here's why i
went through the whole thing and when i
got done with that
the other guy said that's what we need
to do
we need to actually listen what they
have to say we have to take their input
now like all those things we need to
make their plan all those things that we
talk about all the time which is
it's just shocking that people
still you know what they think
tactically
because tactically if i say dave shut up
and do what i told you to do you're
gonna do it
just like this guy did it's a tactical
win hey
the battalion commander says hey you
shut up and do what i told you to do
yeah roger that okay you just won the
tactical battle
but what look what happens look what
happens you won that little tactical
battle
and you lose these other people and and
look
could there have been no one waiting on
that lz absolutely there could have been
no one wait there could have been no
enemy on that lz and everything would
have gone fine and
that guy's that guy's tyrannical
behavior would have been reinforced as
the right way to lead and it ain't the
right way to lead
is not the right way to lead this guy's
a battalion commander he's probably been
leading like that through his whole
career
with with with no consequence certainly
no
n nothing like this to this degree this
story
and you know what makes that happen and
i brought this up with a client the
other day
in the military because i say look you
can be effective with that kind of brow
beating
tyrannical leadership for for
whatever for an hour for a week right i
can just yell dave shut up and do what i
told you to do
and actually in the military i can get
away with it for my whole career why is
that because
you dave you're working for me you know
you only have to work for me
for 18 months right you know it's gonna
take me a couple months to figure myself
out by the time
my tour is starting to look coming to an
end you're not even gonna give me
resistance anymore you're like cool he's
gone and
whatever so these guys can bounce from
job to job to job being in charge of
this group
by the time he leaves they he's hated
yeah but he's accomplished he's quote
accomplished the mission right he's got
his good
fit rep he's done his job he's
accomplished the mission he's hated
they don't want to do it they're
sabotaging him or they're they're
they're sloughing them off they're doing
all those things but no one knows it his
his chain of command
above him thinks oh yeah well he did a
good job he got the mission accomplished
first of all they never got tested
second of all doesn't know the morale of
the troops because that guy's able to
hide it
so that's how these military leaders
sometimes they get through their whole
career
yeah and i mean whole career i'm talking
34-year careers
where they never actually led anybody
all they did was bark orders
and they retire as an admiral they
retire as a general and and they don't
know how to lead
they don't know how to lead no obviously
there's some incredible generals and
admirals
obviously and captains and colonels
obviously
but just because you became an admiral
or you became a colonel or you became a
captain or you became a general
that doesn't mean you knew how to lead
and you know what you if you were
a tyrannical leader
you you can get away with that in the
military yeah you can get away with
because it's only a two-year command
no one wants to they want guess what
everyone below you actually also wants a
good fit rep
so you want a good fit rep so you're
going to bark into everyone and everyone
below you just wants a good
evaluation so they're just going to kind
of follow your lead and put up with it
that i mean that's that
self-preservation i saw that in my
career all the time too
and and we had a term for we called it a
run out the clock scenario
and we'd sit you know and we'd have you
know the young captains the junior guys
would sit around and it was just us and
we'd vent and we'd get frustrated and
i'd see people complain and and i'd see
my peers
getting this off their chest and and
when you do the calculation of hey what
are we going to do about it
are we going to push back are we going
to you know are we going to fight back
up the chain in the end the conclusion
is always
just run out the clock man this guy's
gone in seven months or whatever
or just yeah this guy's gone in seven
months and by the way we have a
we got a two-month trip here he's not
coming with us we got this we got that
he's going to this
thing and it's really what is it we're
going to be face to face with him for
another month
don't worry about it suck it up and and
i don't mean to paint some picture that
we just
sort of resigned ourselves really what
it was was you know what i'm going to
focus my energy on my guys
yeah i'm going to i'm not going gonna
waste my time with this guy
but but it does create that that it it
helps perpetuate the scenario you just
described and
you know to whatever small percentage
there are leaders in the military just
like every other organization
that got their way they they got their
way through
and it and they're not good leaders
because they do exactly
this and and i'm thinking too of of
not just a scenario where you're my
subordinate leader and i go hey
i want it done done this way jocko and
you're not like well mate you know i was
kind of thinking maybe plan b is better
than plan a
you're saying dave no way man
what better position for me as a leader
to have a guy who who
the more emphatic you are about what
you're doing more likely
it's likely that the more loyal you are
and the more you want the outcome to be
good
that's why you're pushing back and if
you're in a leadership position and your
people are pushing back
aggressively that's
even more of a reason to listen to them
because there's clearly
something and what always happens is we
meet we see people meet resistance with
resistance
the more resistance i get the more i
should stop
resisting them or i want to listen now
if you go
well yeah i mean i guess so okay cool
just do my way and that's kind of the
end of the story but if you
if you go to the mat with me no this is
a bad idea
and i'm not gonna listen to that as a
leader why is this person pushing back
because they because they don't care
about the mission they don't care about
the people they don't care about the
outcome
and it is jocko pushing back because
he doesn't because he doesn't care about
his people
because he doesn't want this to be
successful why why would jonko possibly
be
drawing a line in the sand right now
right
yeah there's a re you want to know what
the reason is there's a reason there's a
reason there's a damn good news
and you need to figure it out and also
in this thing
this scenario we're painting where
you're my subordinate leader i also have
to give you a little bit of credit that
you recognize
you are putting your career at risk wait
you're gonna bow up to me
junior subordinate i have to recognize
that you even realize that this is a
sketchy move you're making right now
you're going to the boss and telling him
no
you don't think the subordinate leader
recognizes the risk that he's taking by
by by digging in a little bit and going
boss this is a bad idea
i mean of course i'm sitting here with
the luxury of having
benefited from all the things that
echelon front has done and all the
things
you've written about in all the podcasts
i've listened to it doesn't make it any
less easy to hear this story and picture
that conversation
and know that that tyrannical leadership
is widespread and it's all over the
place
and it doesn't work it's
it's re it's it's frustrating to listen
to that story and you think about you
know the
the catastrophic outcome but even the
subtleties of
of people leading through hey at the end
you know we can go back and forth but in
the end
you're gonna do it my way what a what a
devastating
approach that is to to leading the
people around you
horrible in every possible way
so digging a little bit deeper on this
there was some there was some people
that wrote in to
historynet.com and asked michael
christie for some
more amplifying information here's one
of the letters that got written in
the article last stand at lz hereford by
michael christie had me living the
experiences as if i were there
i served in vietnam with the marines
including 40 days
under siege at compton in 1967.
we always feared a human wave attack
like experienced by the soldiers at
hereford i would like to know if
lieutenant colonel rutland beard was
ever charged with negligence for
ordering charlie company commander cop
captain don warren to leave his mortar
platoon behind in a vulnerable position
with no infantry support
while the rest of charlie moved out also
i was curious to know if
staff sergeant robert kirby was
recognized for his harrowing attempt to
lead a small group of soldiers
and journalist sam caston to safety
i have to wonder how john spranza who is
badly wounded and played dead before his
rescue
and the other survivors are doing today
after their dreadful experience
well for one thing we know that staff
sergeant john kirby though not named
was written about in a very negative way
in this other manual
but guess what michael christie
responded
and here's here's his response
as one would expect the horrors of the
massacre at lz hereford had a tremendous
impact on the lives of those
of all those involved captain don warren
became an alcoholic and eventually
committed suicide
so the the decision that we're sitting
here toiling over
he toiled over it too
sergeant robert kirby retired from the
army and refuses to talk about lz
hereford claiming he remembers almost
nothing about it
although he did receive a silver star
for his part in the battle
god bless him bob
roeder has a severe case of ptsd
but still managed to succeed he married
his high school sweetheart raised a
family and operated a multi-million
dollar medical supply business
john speranza overcame his physical
injuries this is the
so so bob roeder was the last guy
to be recovered the guy that broke down
trying to identify his friends
jon spranzo's got shot in the ear
exit wound in the nose john spranza
overcame his physical injuries but
suffered from emotional damage his
drinking led to three divorces yet the
same determination that saved his life
46 years ago allowed him to work
successfully in two long careers
first in the printing industry and then
as a rural postman for 20
years he and his wife of 26 years are
retired and live in northern georgia
charles stuckey died of cancer six years
ago
no one has heard from isaac johnson
since lz hereford was overrun
no official record exists on rutland
beard receiving any reprimand
he retired from the army as a colonel
as for the company members who rushed to
the rescue
all are still horrified by the carnage
they witnessed once they reached lz
hereford
there's another letter the story of
carnage on
lz hereford is a riveting piece of work
but as noted
it varied glaringly in spots from the
sla martial narrative published 46 years
ago
nonetheless both our authors accurately
capture the overall horror of the event
about a week before the attack described
by christie on a company from another
battalion had been overrun
at hereford and my company from the one
five cab first cav division
was airlifted onto the lz the following
morning to assist
in his book battles in the monsoon
marshall claimed that all
that the kias had been evacuated the
previous evening but i distinctly recall
seeing the pancho covered bodies of the
u.s soldiers
still ringing the landing zone
den and me were everywhere the americans
gave as good as they got
and there's one more little well maybe
not so little
there's one more detail that i want to
go into
so sam caston
the journalist he was married when he
was in vietnam
and he and his wife a woman named
fran caston had moved to hong kong
while he was working in vietnam so they
were
um you know close flight
and he figured well i'll still want to
see you so we'll move to hong kong
and then when i go work in vietnam and
then when i'm not working i'll come back
and they'd been there for about a month
before he was killed
and they had a 13 month old toddler
at the time they're there in hong kong
and after he was killed
she
she packed up she went back to the
states
i mean uh devastated
obviously and not only devastated but
now what
now what you know whatever plans she had
are now obviously
gone
so she had to put her life together
as best she could she she had been at
school
she'd studied english i believe
and she went and started knocking on
doors and eventually got a job at the
new yorker magazine
and then she moved over to the
scholastic
magazine and eventually became a teacher
at the school of visual arts in
manhattan
teaching writing and that is when at age
40 she started to write poetry
and she wrote a poem about her husband
sam caston the brave journalist
who was killed on that awful day and the
poem is called
operation crazy horse
and here it is
a grand kowloon hotel a hedge of red
hibiscus a tiled pool
a masseuse who pressed fragrant oil of
almond into my body
in the full heat of the sun
elsewhere northeast of saigon
a man beheld you
and fired
at the undertakers you were all made up
and your hair was parted wrong so i
smoothed it the way you would have liked
someone shouted stop as if we were
caught making love
on the couch in my father's house
god knows what they feared
unfamiliar streaks in your hair must
have paled
at the moment of terror
and grown longer in the time since
eerie as strands of ticker tape
still printing
such dark hair shocked white
how afraid you were
all i could do
was hold you
and there you go
there is more to every story
and
more for us to learn
and what we need to learn here
in my opinion from all of this
is that your decision and your actions
make a difference and have an impact on
the world
again like this is a an incredible
manual
the squad leader makes a difference and
and
it doesn't just apply to squad leaders
it applies to all of us
your actions make a difference and have
an impact on the world you're gonna
leave a mark
you leave an imprint
on the world and you leave an imprint on
the people around you
so make it a good one
well echo charles yes sir
go ahead man
well it's true we do leave an impact on
the people
around us and we do make a difference
and to make a difference we need to be
capable okay
so we do the right things for ourselves
for the people around us
we start with our physical health
in my opinion as i always say so on our
journey
through improvement and maintaining
physical health you know
we need supplements i give you a hard
time about
just being able to press record sure
because that doesn't seem like a very
hard job
it's not but what i just did to you is
kind of a shitty thing to do isn't it
well you're throwing out challenges and
and i understand
you know i've come to understand these
things which is okay
it's okay for those that might be
joining us for the first time
sometimes the podcast can be a little
much
a little heavy and and so early on
we realized that maybe a little
decompression
would be good i know i need it yeah
i know i need it sometimes so so
i'm sorry for setting you up with the
freaking horrible job
of going from that conversation that we
just had
into whatever it is you're talking about
i'm sorry bro it's okay and you know
what in in the spirit of
of understanding and how should i say
doing my part i should have took what
you said and really
kind of gave my thoughts on it because
my thoughts can be a little bit like
lighter than yours generally so it would
be a little bit of a
a transit a little smoother transition
smoother transition yeah cause you just
went
straight into talking about you know
yeah drinking supplements
yeah you know yeah it's yeah so it was
kind of rough
for sure still true what would your
thoughts have been
um i don't know man that's i guess
that's why i didn't go into it
because i was like dang i should just be
quiet just for a little bit yeah you
know
maybe yeah that's and that's part of the
thing
that's part of the deal is it could that
could just be the end of the podcast i
get it
right but i actually don't want to leave
anyone
that way to be honest with you i don't
want to leave look
the point has been made we get it right
it's true yeah i don't want to leave so
i don't want someone to press stop walk
out and like that's what's going through
their head
yeah they walk into work also right we
need a little
we need to bring it back around right
bring it back the world has darkness in
it right we just saw that
yeah we just saw that yeah
by the way the author the the his wife
fran caston she's alive she's in
like east hampton or something she's out
there
writing poems yeah maybe we'll hear from
her
you know yeah i mean given the
circumstances it's like
okay isn't it it's uh what do you call
like
good to meet you but not under these
circuits yeah
that whole deal that's a common one
anyway all right
well how can we make a difference if
we're not capable
right true we'll just say it's hard i
would say
we're we want to make a good mark on the
world
yeah how do we do that what what how how
do you suggest
us doing a better job of leaving
a positive impression on people and on
the world
i say keep your stuff together cool got
it edited together
clean yeah
uh you know get it together keep it dude
yeah dave burke over here so bored he's
reading freaking cans
he's reading ingredients from go i'm not
saying you're wrong
he's looking at that's like a what do
you call like a not
vanity but he's looking at his own can
he's like oh
my goodness fyi
i just happen to notice that these are
two different cans so it caught my
attention oh really oh i see that too
now
yeah so i told you i i guess i could be
more vain than i am but honestly i'm
just
just now barely noticing that these are
different cans of the same drink yeah
because right before that you're looking
at your fingernails and like you're you
know
i don't know if you worked out today
you're looking at your physique
i saw the whole deal i saw the whole
deal so all good and oh or
or he could be bored whichever well
you've successfully lightened the mood
all right well hold on you know i press
record i do
things from time to time nonetheless
when we're working out we need
supplements
joints get take a beating sometimes
we've got supplements for your joints
you need protein okay so if you're
working out hard and hard isn't you know
depends on who you are whatever you need
a certain amount of protein to
facilitate the gains
or should i say the results okay ah you
said gains i
did you said gains you spelled it with a
z i saw it
the point is you need a certain amount
of protein otherwise not we buy not
going to recover
recover correctly do you know the
protein
range yeah not much yeah
see yes one gram no
what go ahead you're like shaking your
actually i'm sorry i'm sorry i
interrupted you go ahead how many what
one gram
per lean but one gram per pound of lean
body mass
yeah i think that's correctly i think
that's the old school it's actually less
than the new school okay the new school
is a range from 0.6 okay to
i mean one that's high one gram per
you know stuff yeah it might it starts
to level out i think at like point eight
or something like
this okay nonetheless not everyone knows
that is what i'm trying to say
so and furthermore not only do
do not a lot of people know that it's
hard to do that
unless you're like just that's your jam
you know you're planning the week and
all that not all of us do that you know
i didn't realize that so look let's say
you have 180
five pounds of lean body mass and you're
trying to get the point
seven we'll say it's a lot of protein
not for you i'm not no problem not for
you i know but i'm just saying for the
rest of us you know like when you don't
think about sum everything up that
echoes trying to stand right now you
need more
let's say i didn't say any of that okay
what if i just said hey you need more
people to be like
all right you have failed points
describe why need milk i'll stand down
but can you hurry a little bit i'm
standing down but okay you just like we
get the mess do you wanna
do you though do you get the message i
think we get the message bro
i honestly i don't think you do and
that's why i'm here oh see if it was
between you and dave you'd be like
drink more okay it tastes good they'll
be like bread you know you think a lot
of stuff tastes good
anyway take them off bro you get it some
discipline go
you never bring it like this i like it
anyway
speaking of discipline go okay and
and bear with me here bear with me
so discipline go it's a thing it tastes
good it's a little drink
kind of like a soda mm-hmm yeah i mean
okay
it's not like a soda but it's like a
soda so and i'm
gonna tell a little story short so you
know how like when you go to the movies
right
you go to the movies yep do you get no
soda and popcorn at the movies
sure dave burke soda popcorn i use
sometimes right
yeah yeah i understand so you go to the
movies you get your soda you get your
popcorn you just have to
you watch the movie with your kids it's
awesome right you come home
and you kind of remember whether it be
later that night or the next day you're
like oh yeah that was a cool movie like
man but i ate that whole thing of
popcorn you know many calories are in
popcorn in junk calories too by the way
there's a difference i have no idea it's
a lot it's like 2 000
it depends on how big the popcorn is and
then you got the soda right and there's
a small tinge of guilt
that comes with you same thing with the
brownies
same thing with the other stuff that you
eat don't act like oh the
pretzel pretzel wrapped hot dogs that my
wife made for me on super bowl sunday i
somehow might i forget where everyone
was but like they came out of the oven
and my fam wasn't around and i was like
i'll just have one or two while my
family's not around i racked it i had a
half a rack half a tray
i crushed them how big was the tree uh i
don't know this is like a cookie
type oh like a sheet like a regular
standard yeah like a stainless
steel it must have been at least i'm
gonna go ahead and say
20 20 of them 20 of those things can you
figure
like no like no factor that's why 300
calories per
probably maybe two they're really small
yeah but those are like sausages with
freaking straight up biscuits wrapped up
like okay
that's who knows oh yeah
it sounded nice but and you i get it
like you'll just go punish you know
you'll pay the price the next day
that's the protocol i get it's the next
day a lot of us we got a little bit more
like
guilt and we're like man i kind of just
shouldn't have done that you know
anyway the point is when you drink the
discipline go and the malt too
by the way you get that same sort of
satisfaction
that you would have had with the soda or
the freaking oreo cookie
shake from the drive-thru or wherever
you get that same front end but you get
a way better backhand you see what i'm
saying well you get actually positivity
exactly right it's actually better what
was weird was i kind of thought about it
because i had a milkshake with a banana
by the way
oh and the next house like man last
night i had that dessert i was like wait
the dessert wasn't
something junk it was something good
yeah so it's like you get the refreshing
you got a double positive hit actual
protein
getting to your point seven yeah yeah
then you've got
the not even guilt-free but positivity
yeah so
this is like across the board win-win
front end backhand tactical strategic
all good stuff appreciate that they've
got a bunch of other stuff there
super krill vitamin d3 cold war
war your kids mole you've got all kinds
of good stuff
you can get it from jockofield.com and
by the way if you subscribe to any of
these things
the shipping is free because we know
that that was kind of an issue
people are like do i want this stuff but
shipping is expensive
we're trying to allow people to
more easily stay on the path and also if
you're just
if you're just a person that doesn't
quite stay on track
that doesn't quite it's a thing do
things that they're supposed to do
and they end up saying well i actually
ran out of joint warfare or whatever
just subscribe echo charles just
subscribe if you subscribe it's coming
yeah
and it's free shipping get some uh
jackalful.com
also you can get the you can get the the
drink
at wawa chain wide
by the way chain wide apparently there's
some insurgency happening
some other some other brands are trying
to
you know maneuver
and they're getting ambushed so i
appreciate everyone going in there and
and and just getting after it clearing
shelves
yeah and it tells kind of a good story
corey
corey he he he went in with a cooler
he literally clearly he posted it he
literally cleared cleared
the the can the the fridge out yeah you
can imagine the guy at the front desk or
the cashier guys like bro
why do you have a cooler in here he's
like oh cause i'm gonna go
my current favorite thing to do is i get
tagged on
on instagram all the time of people
doing that and i just
put it on my story and it's just story
after story of people going in
tagging wawa and just emptying the
shelves and like buying everything they
can it is awesome i
appreciate everyone getting after that
and you can also get all the supplement
the whole line at uh vitamin shop
and like i said free shipping
if you if you subscribe if you might
also need
jiu jitsu a jiu-jitsu you might need a
rash guard you can get all that stuff
from origin
usa.com by the way implement it
implement it originusa.com
you can get that there all this good
stuff and plus
if you if you ever are off the mats of
justice and you need something to wear
because we know what we're wearing on
the mats right we're wearing
our origin ghee or our origin rascard
but if you're off the master justice and
you need
clothing which you do you can get jeans
you can get boots
you can get dang we got socks coming
what
you get everything we're getting there
we're getting where we get everything
all that's all that's made in america
made in america
which is which is what we are doing to
rebuild manufacturing in this country so
go to originusa.com get whatever you
need
also if you need more stuff you know
to wear off the mats and on by the way
go to jackalstore.com now here you can
find
your more disciplined
themed i don't like the word theme but
more disciplines
slanted skewed apparel okay here's the
thing you do want to represent one
when you're on the path you do think
about what you are representing though
let's face it you you do run the risk of
representing the same thing your
neighbor across the street who's not on
the path by the way
is represented are you an elitist
my neighbor across the street is a
badass well then okay then there you go
that's cool but i'm saying you do run
the risk
got it see what i'm saying look if you
have discipline equals freedom or you
have good or you have like one of the
hoodies or something like this
you don't run that risk you see what i'm
saying so if you're gonna represent on
the path here this is a good place to
get the stuff
and it's a good move overall where do
you get it jockostore.com
we have a little subscription situation
going on too called the shirt locker
that's a different
it's not different but it's kind of
different
jack it's a shirt every month cool new
design exclusive you can't get them in
the store otherwise
can't these new ones you're you're into
this elite
kind of elite shirt where i'm i'm just
i'm just letting them know
letting everyone know nonetheless called
the shirt locker it's on jocklestore.com
so yeah sign up for that man if
if you think that that's cool if you
think you want to represent in that way
that's a good
good good deal roger that subscribe to
this podcast also we got the jocko
unraveling we got the grounded podcast
we got the warrior kid podcast we also
have the
jocko underground jackoground.com
where we give some amplifying
information
other things different topics different
subjects behind the scenes we're setting
up for a q a
right yeah and that's like questions
like okay so i get it dave burke
jocko echelon front they get it they're
gonna say hey how do i
how do i get buy-in from the team right
that's a common one it doesn't have to
be pro
uh questions about like work what to do
at work you can be outside of work
yeah anyway we're setting that up yeah
it's set up
so you go to questions at
jackonground.com
submit your question submit an audio or
video question too dude
i that's you're proactive you just made
that happen
the squad leader makes a difference i
make a difference yes sir
i'm trying over here doing my best are
you the trooper squad leader
if you if you want to if you want to get
all this and you want to support us you
can go to jockowunderground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month
which is a number with layers
and and that just protects us from
number one having to be a slave
to sponsors and protects us from
if we if from people saying they didn't
want to they don't want to host us
anymore
they can try it we got it we'll be
standing by
execute contingency plan so thanks to
everyone that's supporting
on that we got a youtube channel we got
a youtube channel
that echoed charles he makes videos
and i am the assistant director of the
good ones
which is important to know also origen
bjj has has it they're putting some cool
videos up as well check that one out
check out that one also psychological
warfare and album don't forget about
this okay sometimes we can
shy away from the support that we need
it's insane sometimes we need this
support when we want to
slip on the diet you know skip the
workout turn a workday into a rest day
let's face it that's a thing
anyway psychological warfare is an album
where jack was telling you
why you just shouldn't do that and then
you won't do it so anyway you can find
that on amazon and
you know wherever you buy mp3's boom
psychological warfare
is there for you also flipsidecanvas.com
my brother dakota meyer making cool
stuff to hang on your wall the coolest
stuff to hang on your wall you're gonna
hang something on your wall
is if you're going to hang something on
your wall don't you want to look at it
and say
that's from dakota meyer yes that's a
hundred percent
i can't believe i've never said that
before yes that's 100 what i want if i'm
hanging something on my wall i want it
to be
from dakota meyer yeah i agree with that
flipsidecanvas.com if you want that we
got a bunch of books
final spin what is it
it's it's an it's a knob dave
assessment you've read final spin oh i
have
assessment i'd like i actually kind of
secretly want to know where i sit in the
log of readers where am i actually you
know what i haven't gotten you i haven't
gotten you the
final version the final final one it is
not
just a book i can tell you that for sure
dang yeah interesting
it is they're going to have a hard time
figuring out where to put this one on
the bookshelf yes
they put it over there and they put it
over there in the yeah
like like where does it go they have a
hard time my my validation
that it wasn't just me just
digging what i was reading is i shared
it with my wife which
i gotta be honest i don't there's not a
lot of crossover
in my world that i'm doing like i don't
share all this stuff with my wife we got
other stuff going on i don't like
you know bombarded with work stuff
you're not talking about battles in the
bond soon nope
i'm not how was the podcast it was
awesome okay cool what do i need to do
around the house how can i help
i know i've been gone for seven hours i
shared this with her
and she just burned through it i think
in two days
you know and burned through it was like
10 o'clock at night gets into bed and
she stays up way too late and finishes
in two nights and she's like that was
really good
that's when i knew like my version of it
being good had to be validated by a
totally disinterested third party
with no no bias yeah she was totally
stoked
well interestingly my mom
uh so you would think what you just said
like oh
bias right you'd think oh i send it to
my mom that's a given
right you know my mom my mom
like it's because she was an english
teacher and so she's just
there to just just she's just there i
would say throw darts but she's not
there to throw darts she's there to huck
machetes at your work at my work right
and so i sent it to her for a final read
and she sent me a text that said like
halfway done i am loving this book that
was complete shock
yeah in fact i told life about it
because life was life was with me
in new york city when extreme ownership
made number
number one new york times bestseller
which is which is like
sort of the thing the cool thing for a
book right
and i i called my parents on
speakerphone
and and lace like standing there listen
i'm like hey i just want to let you guys
know you know we made new york times
best-selling list
you know with the book that i wrote with
leif
and my mom's like oh well we'll see how
long it's on there for him
i was like cool yeah i guess we will
[Music]
so a positive review yeah and it'll be
interesting you know you go into a
bookstore and they have
i guess categories whatever they yeah
i'll be interested to see where they put
it
i will too it's going to be it's going
to be very interesting so we got that
if you want to pre-order that thing it's
also it's all hey why pre-order
well so you can get it because once
again we don't want you to not get it we
don't you want definitely don't want you
to not get
a first a dish it's a big deal
when you you want that first to dish
and here's the other thing the
the publisher my publisher
do you think they're nervous about this
they are nervous
they're nervous because they're like you
you just suppose we're supposed to write
leadership books i'm like what about all
those kids well yeah that too
are you gonna write a novel don't you
just want to stay in your little lane
over here
no
so put them at ease
before they freak out so final spin
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocols discipline equals freedom
field manual the way of the warrior kid
four field manual
way the warrior kid one two and three
miking the dragons about face
by david hackworth extreme ownership
and the dichotomy of leadership echelon
front it's a leadership consultant so
you can hear dave and i talking about it
today
this is what we do we solve problems
through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details
ef online it's
leadership training for everyone
efonline.com it's it's where you can get
your whole team
training tomorrow it's tomorrow
you have to do something crazy enough to
contact that you can go to echelon go to
efonline.com you can start training
tomorrow
the muster in 2021 we got these things
lined up go to extreme ownership.com
it's our live
event all these have sold out these are
gonna sell out to ef overwatch if you
need leaders inside your company go to
efoverwatch.com
and we have leaders that understand the
principles we talk about they can go in
your company and help
you win and if you want to help service
members
service members active retired you want
to help their families you want to help
gold star families
check out mark lee's mom mama lee she's
got a charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org and if you want
more of my protracted parables
or you need some more of echo's
perplexing
postulations or
you just crave some more of dave's super
serious
sagas
[Music]
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on instagram
which echo only knows as the graham and
on facebook dave is at david r burke
echoes at echo charles and i am at jocko
willink and thanks to all the people
out there in uniform all of you all the
military
the police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers
border patrol secret service first
responders
and all of your families
waiting at home thanks to all of you
for making a difference every single day
with what you do and everyone else out
there
keep learning keep evolving
and never forget that your decisions and
your actions
they make a difference not just in your
life
but in the lives of other of other
people
and don't just go through life don't
just go with the flow
be intentional about what you're doing
set things
in order leave
a positive mark in the world
you do make a difference
and until next time this is dave and
echo
and jocko out